the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
grand masters continued to regale us
with brilliant play at the sinkfield cup
in saint louis as the world mourns the
loss of a queen the kings of chess gave
performances worthy of any royal court
young phenom a laressa farousha quickly
dispatched of chakriar mama diarov to
join a crowd in second place superstar
wesley so is eyeing another gct crown
after defeating hans neiman to improve
his lead and the chances of extending
his reign the battle for the cup is
still raging who will rule the day round
seven of exciting chess coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day seven of
the sinkhole cup held at the saint louis
chess club it's been a fantastic
tournament so far and the action is
heating up let's go to the studio and
start today's round with yasser peter
and alejandro
[Music]
from the home of chess in america
welcome to the sinkhole cup the flagship
event of the saint louis chess club and
the final stop on the 2022 grand chess
tour
hello and welcome to round seven i'm
peter svidler and with me is yasser
saravan very very happy to see you today
likewise peter as always very happy to
see you too hello everyone and welcome
to our broadcast well the hurricane
continues to swirl around us and gary
kasparov has asked
magnus carlson for a statement but thus
far none has been forthcoming in the
meanwhile
yesterday round six saw our most
decisive round at the tournament peter
do the honors and tell us our current
standings let's take a look after round
six yesterday in which indeed we had
three decisive games out of four right
standings are as follows wesley is
leading the tournament but not by a full
point as this uh this cross across table
might indicate because of the different
number of games people played exactly he
is on four out of six but alireza and
yanipanishi aren't three out of five not
three out of six meaning that they are
in effect half a point behind wesley uh
tied for second and third then we have
four players on 50
and uh maxima shiela grab who needed a
decent event here to perhaps clinch the
uh the overall gct victory is
languishing on minus two as is uh
charlie armamentary and peter our format
please
absolutely uh the format is uh a
nine-player round robin uh with a 90
minutes for first 40 moves and 30
minutes for the rest of the game with a
half a minute increment starting from
the very beginning draw offers remain
disallowed right and
the the standard scoring system is being
used for the classical tournaments and
our remaining schedule peter there are
many schedules pretty straightforward
starting from today we've only got three
rounds to go uh they will be played
today tomorrow and on sunday
if uh
two or more players end up getting tied
the first in this tournament the
playoffs will happen the same evening
and if the gcc points end up tied that
playoff will be postponed until monday
the 12th
and the closing ceremony is in the
evening of
the 12th
the world can rejoice as alejandro is in
studio good to see you alejandro good to
see you guys a pleasure to be here and
what a tournament we've had not only
because of the drama but the games
themselves have been great and let's not
forget we are playing for the grand
chess tour 2022 and that means that we
have to look at the standings in the
tour itself with wesley leading the sing
field cup let's see how that affects our
standings this is the current standards
before the same field cup starts mvl in
the lead with 26 and a half points
followed very closely only one point
behind by his compatriot alireza
ferrugia off of a superb st louis rapid
and blitz but there's a couple of people
there that you can see with not that
many points less levona ronyan and
wesley so certainly savoring a good
tournament here and thinking we can pass
those frenchmen and let's see what would
happen if the tournament finishes right
now and considering that we use this
plus-minus score so for example alaresa
ferruga who is on three out of five
we're counting that differently than if
he was on three out of six and this
would be the current standings if we
finish the tournament right now wesley
so with 35 and a half points because of
his first place lead at the moment would
catapult himself as the winner of the
grand chess tour 2022 but it's not a
comfortable lead alireza is only one
point behind that means that a slight
switch in the standings might mean that
already is the one that overtakes me
meanwhile maxima sherlock currently in
first place all the way down to third
because of the poor performance here at
the same field cop he's gonna have to
put a couple of win to get wins together
and let's not forget levona ronyan just
beat mvl might also be trying to climb
those standings this is far from over
this is a tournament and especially a
grand chess tour that is up for grabs
not by one two or three people but i
think there's many people trying to look
at it and saying i want to win the tour
i still have a shot at it and we're
going to have to see how this develops
we have a crucial last three rounds of
the grand chester coming up but of
course there's got there's been a lot of
drama around the tournament and there's
going to be a lot of social media
interests and tell us all about it we
have woman grandmaster anastasia
karlovic thank you alejandra and hello
everyone of course after magnus carlson
withdrew from the tournament we have all
this storm and in the media in the
social media as well and of course we
are following the development of the
story and everybody was waiting for the
statement from magnus carlson from
chess.com and actually we got it uh you
can see first of all the tweet from
honiger who also lost his sleep waiting
for the for news and he's made the
statement that if anyone wants to make
any statements please do it soon it's
bedtime here so
we managed to get one just after this
tweet i mean the it was released the
statement from chess.com who sent the
the team sent the message to hans
niemann clearly and now it's a question
what hans will answer um maybe today
we'll have some news from him and um
daniel ranch made it sure that his
intentions are good and uh
despite the hate and opinions all around
i
want to what's the best for hans and
chess this is what he said in his tweets
in his tweet which followed after the
statement and of course the media keeps
following the event and we found mangus
carlson yesterday he was in uh with uh
aryan tari his friend grandmaster from
norway we found him an instagram account
of aryan and then um
media is following of course closely the
development and you can see all the
biggest
newspapers who published the articles
quite detailed articles about what's
going on here in saint louis and not
only here and then we also have a funny
story from peter heine nielsen who had
his flight um chicago helsinki and
the person who was sitting next to him
asking what he was doing here and he
answered chess coaching and then he was
asking actually what's going on now with
this
chess drama peter actually spoke about
it yesterday in our in our show but i
decided to repeat it because i think
it's really funny and then of course i'm
inviting everyone to follow the news in
our instagram accounts but if you would
like to know more information of course
you should definitely read recaps at
granchester.org which are written by
international master costa kavutski who
is here our journalist for grand chester
i mean if you want to learn more and see
all this drama how it started and all
the development you should definitely
visit the official website for more
information so that's what's happening
now that the around uh the round is
about to start and i would like to come
back to peter and yes sir well thank you
anastasia i suggest you don't call it
anastasia's corner but anastasia's
circle is in a circle of friends because
you certainly do have your work cut out
for you and peter as we're getting
around started i just wanted to say
lay the table for us and tell us about
today's pairings what can our viewers
expect uh the pairings for around seven
are on your screen shakira yamamitarov
is white against
uh tournament yeah somebody who is
having a poor tournament versus somebody
who is still very much in the running
for first in this in this event right
lanier dominguez is playing against
another person who is tied for uh second
today and remember there at the bottom
our tournament leader is not in action
today he wouldn't be playing magnus but
as it is he has a rest day so the people
tied for second
are very very interested in catching up
to him today uh mvl is white uh against
uh hans niemann and that is also a game
that we would very very much uh like to
watch and of course we also have five
against levon
and in all of this fighting chess that
we've been witnessing what are they
fighting for peter
the price fund for uh gc events is a
very very generous uh 350 thousand
dollars total uh there is a hundred
grand up top for the winners and uh yeah
it's just a very very lucrative very uh
well-paid series of tournaments uh for
which we are
uh well they they are very grateful and
the gct fort's starting to heat up and
those playoffs that you've been
mentioning could happen as we see the
players coming in
and getting uh very carefully wanted
these days and of course along with this
very lucrative prize fund which you've
mentioned we're very happy that brian
priester is continued his support for
the tournament through his brilliancy
prize absolutely as you can see on your
screen there is an additional five
thousand dollars donated by brian
priester of key west florida uh which uh
the four of us alejandro yasser
anastasia and myself will uh will
determine which which game earns the
sounds like good work to me okay you
give me a chance to review all the games
yes it will be a nice opportunity to
once again revisit uh the uh the the
things that were produced by the players
here and there's already been a a number
of games which will be hotly contesting
that the traditional prize
is that we see napo stepping
up your turn coming up
i noticed
couldn't help but notice as we came in
today to do our broadcast that we are
getting tested for the covet
the players as well is that a daily
routine do you know i'm not entirely
sure but uh
i i assume there are protocols in place
and uh
the club has always been very careful on
uh on that topic from my from my years
of uh working uh here during the
pandemic so yeah i'm sure there's uh
proper proper attitudes in place
proper attitudes indeed uh of the four
the four games that we're expecting
today what did you uh think will be our
more key match up where is the
excitement going to come from in today's
it's always easier once you see at least
the first five like exactly exactly but
uh
you you you kind of
you can't turn away right you you want
to watch hans yes
okay
every day every day you you can continue
very much wanting uh wanting to watch
hans there's there's plenty of other
stuff as well i think linear versus
alireza isn't potentially an interesting
matchup because uh and this one too
and this is a very very uh you know
storied
uh story heads up there uh between uh
fabi and levon let me actually check
because we we've had a certain pairing
which was nearing was it this one
actually uh the the 200 game that was
magnus levon that was magnus first that
was amazing alejandra jump in uh where
do you think uh today the excitement is
going to be
the tactics i think everybody wants to
see the hans neiman game right but i
particularly want to see it after i did
my spiel on the granchester standings
right because if maxine can put a couple
of wins together he's playing with white
today he's right back there in the mix
he wants to win not just the sinfield
cup but the gcd so for me this is a
crucial game for maxine he needs to
bounce back he is playing with the white
pieces this is a crucial game for the
frenchman absolutely i just noticed by
the way in the game between lanier and
perugia we have an open sicilian on the
board and uh yeah it
likely neither
and uh linear has
plenty of ideas against the night of he
is one of the more i think concrete and
the more sort of well-prepared players
against the night off and he never shies
away from a theoretical discussion there
so that would be that would be
interesting to watch somewhat alarmingly
we might have a berlin in the game
between 5b and left but lev is still
thinking
and lev is at some point i think he was
my sort of final partner in crime or
perhaps a a partner in you know lack of
crime
yeah yeah because we were maybe the last
two i mean i no longer really count them
in that list but play ac
morphe defense somewhat somewhat notable
players who kind of played the classical
spanish right and just went bishp7 here
and uh quite happily right uh played all
these types of lines but both you and
and lev really uh
i
wanna say really uh put your career into
the marshall too yeah
in later years i think uh it became
quite obvious to a lot of people that
you could bluff me in that position you
just had on the board please play c3 and
i would kind of frown and scowl for like
five minutes and play g6 instead of d5
because
who has the memory for those things but
uh yeah in in early years i would have
snapped played g5 there and even in in
somewhat
more recent times i have played the
marshall occasionally look at what we do
have in fact on screen
uh in the game between levon uh
well
it was that was believe it berlin just
well not really commentators curse not
not really and actually the position
they're playing uh we could
it's an incredibly incredibly forcing
line and there are some very sharp end
games which could arise like
we could potentially like 10 minutes
later we'd be playing a very very sharp
heavily theoretical end game with like
70 percent of all the pieces trade at
all and they have a lot of experience in
this line as well but it's it's not the
berlin it's the inc berlin and it's one
of the sharpest anti berlins in
existence so i'm not that saddened by
this all right and jeb wright and
alejandro in the game between fabi
and lavonne we're kind of off a little
bit the beaten track but
no what do you mean we're following the
game caruana ironian there we go so
they're very familiar with it they've
played it against each other i think
this was back in 2019
yeah 2019. so fabi has actually played
this variation several times i think the
first time i saw him live play this line
was against jeffrey shong in the u.s
championship of 2017 right that game he
had and then advantage from the opening
he let it go then he was worse and the
game ended in a draw if i remember
correctly so very experienced this
fabian with this particular
flavor of the anti-berlin and since
these two players are so well versed in
this line i want to see where they try
to one-up each other
very very good uh remember now there was
some queen takes d watch yeah yeah black
basically goes for e5 before very very
quickly it looks like a a2 maybe not
immediately although here it's also
playable and there's uh some very high
profile games which started like this
like mvl had this on the white side
against kramnik and jeffrey shong play
this again fabi so fabi actually knows
uh quite a lot about this position has
had it uh a number of times but levon
did castle did not play e4 yet and it
looks kind of striking right because
white goes a4 says you you have a bishop
on your wrists i'm gonna trap your
vision yeah there's there's heads up and
a5 here is basically never played crazy
which is which is the crazy yeah which
is the crazy part because uh the counter
play in the center is just too strong so
you don't have time for it you have to
prepare it first alejandro how do these
two players do in their head-to-head
match-ups
i let's take a look
13 wins for 589 losses and a bunch of
draws 27 draws between these two players
and i know that favi's gotten the best
of love in recent years i think very
importantly there was this victory in
the american cup right which
i mean favi won quite convincingly in
that tournament
so
i want to see where this rivalry
develops levoncha switching to the us
federation means that they're going to
be playing in so many more tournaments
that they already do
because we're adding both the american
cup and the us championship to the mix a
tournament which both of these players
are going to be participating in and i
want to say three weeks i mean the
action just doesn't stop here in sydney
it's true but 49 games peter i'm trying
to think uh and i i checked briefly this
is just the classical the rapid right
the rapidem blitz adds another hundred
another hundred yeah so there's there's
a lot of history there there's like
around 150 games all told and and that's
not counting online i assume they played
a decent amount online exactly but uh
also it's kind of
convincing
13 to 9 13 is not yeah that's it's a
decent advantage for sure yeah now
tell me why you you play the move a4
trapping the bishop and nobody plays a5
come on peter what's up with that uh
well
if you prepare it for one more move you
will i assume be able if i hear i guess
you you get hit by 5v4 and you don't
like that as much as you perhaps you
would
and if i take a [ __ ] this is just not
great
because the king is stuck on e1 and you
have to take on f3 you will get the at
the very least we can recapture on b6
but also bishop g4 might be quite
awkward knight e5 might be quite awkward
this is
not why for me the bigger question would
be what happens if we go a5 e4 g takes
e4 yeah and whether there is some way to
sacrifice stuff or we are just taking on
d1 and taking on f2 that might just be
the simplest this is the simplest but
maybe maybe there is something even
smarter but at the very least you can
definitely do or knight takes e4 that
takes if i'm a bit worried i will be
yeah sacrificing sacrifice and chorus
which is bishop to xf2 in this position
and
uh
black gets a lot of play but still it's
it's interesting that a5 just does not
exist
on our screen there there is like 65
games white played knight bg2 and 38 of
them queen e2 in 20 and you can also
castle here and as we say all these
things knight bg2 has been played this
is by far the most popular the main move
in this position
it is funny isn't it alejandro you play
a4 to trap the bishop and you don't
follow it up with a5 it's it's an irony
it's modern chess and after the move
knight bd2 bishop f5 blitz style bishop
f5 blitzed out and there's kind of a
funny story because in this particular
position i've casted this position
between karana and aronian and in one of
those games left played the move a5
right and after b5
in the 2018 i want to say this was the
finals of the grand chester in london
um
probably got a huge advantage anaya's
left you know what was up with a5 and he
said oh i just forgot to play bishop f5
and a couple of months later fabi got
this position against karjakin
and karjakin played the move e4
and somebody asked karyaki what's what's
e4 and he said oh i forgot that it's
bishop f5
okay it's really good yeah and now
bishop five has been played bishop a33
somebody got it right peter yeah bishop
by three and this is actually the end
game i was referring to it's i think my
understanding is is it's supposed to be
equal as is you know with many topical
lines here which pay three you play five
before because now b5 actually is a much
stronger thread than a5 so you play e5
e4 here okay uh it's already been played
d494 bishop and knight e4 all of this is
on the board black generally takes on e4
with the bishop because if you take on
d1 like before b5 will actually attack a
lot of materials so you you keep the
queen on the six for the time being
bishop takes e4 before 26 cd6
and white generally i think maybe even
immediately goes long castles here right
yeah load castles is by far the main
move in this position oh my goodness and
this is there's a a very very serious
amount of well you can call it it's kind
of interesting how we sort of use the
words theory and practice
interchangeably right right because
whenever we refer to theory
it is actually sort of practice
it's not actually theory
what we've done in practice yeah yeah
we're referring to the games that have
already been shown
of course many of those games in
particular at the top level started off
as people analyzing the same position
but by this point i think those those
terms are used in a kind of a weird
chess specific chess specific way but
this is a game which which saw a well
long history of very very high level uh
high level involvement and uh the point
here of course is that uh white has well
not a majority yet but the pollen d6 is
vulnerable right and if the pawn on six
does fall let's say in exchange for the
pawn on f2 right
white will have a majority on the queen
side yep with the king already somewhere
around the beetle square rook ac8 in the
meantime already played bishop d5 also
blitzed out both of these guys know what
they're doing here this is still as i
mentioned a very very heavily trafficked
theoretical position
and white is basically claiming that
uh with with our king in the center or
maybe even on the queen's side of the
environment
so supportive of our push yeah we have a
little bit of a of a nibble here
but
of course you know this being uh such an
important theoretical position and we're
still actually following the game
between
uh fabian left from 2018 which five
ended up winning
uh if you go into this line with black
uh you know the assumption has to be
that you looked at it seriously because
you you these guys are pretty convincing
i think they've looked at it seriously
but yeah this is exactly what i mean
that basically that this is
uh king bitsu is uh sort of the the king
c2 or king king pizza because you i
think you want the sidestep bishop
before tactics uh he's played king city
he played very soon it's not it's not a
non-existent move but it's a much rarer
move than you're saying so
king p2 is the standard yeah king bitsu
is what they generally do in this
position and there's more than 20 games
from here and only two games in our
database after king seeds our database
is a kind of a
wow
[Music]
well by far the most popular move has
been king b2 and
30 odd games in our database
king c2 twice only twice yeah
and uh
as i wanted to mention like our database
doesn't include like recent rapid and
blitz games so perhaps those numbers
like people watching might have a clear
idea actually if somebody in our in our
audience is like in possession of a good
online database like including all of
the engine games and so on right they
might have a clearer clear view as to
how rare this this is really well the
first thing that kind of comes to my
mind what happens
and we've got d4 when the king is on b2
i can't play bishop d4 exactly and this
is why i think people just sort of
automatically played king between that
position but exactly um yeah
and what's he got up a sleeve very
understandably there is now a pause from
there
right like he needs to what's that a
just uh adjust to the
changing circumstance i don't quite know
what the idea is after bishop takes f2
we could discuss it by the way
alejandro what is white's quote winning
percentage out of the move king b2 which
looked pretty normal and what's our
winning percentage with this king c2 it
is a hundred percent draw except
for karana ronyan
from the 2018
grand chester finals in london the first
one that i mentioned was the classic and
the one that favi won was in the rapid
so when when levon forgot to play bishop
f5 he played a5 instead that was the
classic version and then they went into
a tie break they got to this position
five played king b2 and eventually won
the end game it's the only person that's
ever won this end game nobody has ever
lost it with white a lot of these games
are correspondence games so that
shouldn't be such a surprise but it has
been played in let's call it real chess
in several other occasions now the move
king c2 it sent lev into a pause but it
has been played before and it's a
straight upon sacrifice bishop takes f2
as you guys mentioned you cannot take on
e5 because bishop d4 forks the rook and
the pawn and that's pretty much the end
of the game right uh instead i expect
that after bishop takes f2 he'll play
the move b5 this is what the engines are
saying this is like a favi type of
position
there's two options you could play rook
fe-8 but then if you move the rook off
of the f-file which defended this guy
then i can play rook f1
the bishop has to retreat to h4 there's
no other option i'll explain why in a
second and after rook d7 you have to
find this kind of clever move e4 why e4
because you can't hold on to this pawn
you just can't do it you can play f5
loose this way but if you play f6 you
trap your own bishop i start playing g3
i keep i keep the i keep the bishop on
the king side and i start collecting
your queen side pawns so instead you
have to find this move e4 so that you
have counter play retreating the bishop
to f6 that guards either the g7 square
or it connect it loses the connection of
the rooks here also e3 is a threat in
some positions and
you'll have some kind of computer saying
about equal in this position there's
another way to do things is that after
b5 challenge the rook on the d file
which is i think a more human approach
to the position and the idea is that
after rook ht1 only move according to
the engine black still has some things
to resolve first of all if i take kind
of naively
then it looks like after e4 the black is
up a pawn right but look at the activity
difference between the kings
king on c2 already catching this pawn on
e4 very easy access to the center this
guy
not so easy i'm gonna put a rook on d7
this bishop is already cutting it out of
f8 even when you do get f5 your king's
not really getting in i'm gonna be able
to take on b7 and then the question is
which pawns are more powerful it's true
this one's more advanced than anything
white has right now and it's connected
past pawn but it's gonna get stuck on
the e3 square if i even put it there why
because of this powerful king i also
have always the option of covering via
rook e7 so in essence even though on a
vacuum the pawns look more dangerous
once you analyze the king position it's
clear that white is preferable in this
position that's why the engines don't
really like taking on d5 here they
prefer the move bishop b6 which was
played in the only correspondence game
that reached this position the point is
that now the move rook takes the a just
leads to a position in which white is
down a pawn so you have to be more
creative than that the rook d7 move here
it is not as powerful the problem is
that after f6 and i take on b7 black has
this idea of taking on c3 uh rook takes
d1 king takes d1 rook takes c3 regains
the pawn and lost on b7 and black is up
upon so instead of that after bishop b6
the move the engine is saying is bishop
b4 kind of kg the idea is to just play
a5 remove this bishop from the b6 square
it's not so comfortable to answer e4 is
possible a5 is also possible and if you
take take and go a5
a rookie take root takes e5 also
possible because bishop d4 now doesn't
hit the pawn on c3 you get an equal
ending according to the engines but you
look you give me this position
anything but equal right i would be as
scared as black that this one is pretty
powerful that white is very active and
that my pawns it doesn't matter how many
i have quantity is not as important as
quality and i start looking at the c
pawn running with decisive effect
meanwhile if i'm wide as i think well
wait a second that's a lot of pawns if i
don't actually get my opponent c on the
c file to do something eventually these
pawns will be telling so it's a super
double edged position you guys want more
double edged position i'll just put it
for you guys
take a look at the other reza's game
yeah this is theory actually it's a
theory like this is theory but it's
still fun yeah absolutely but we do have
uh uh we do have one potentially very
dry but very heavy theoretical fight and
then we have this yeah the uh the the
fibre versus the one game and the
absolute craziness that is the game
between uh linear dominguez and ali reza
ferrogia where uh this looks like one of
those knight g4 english attacks yes it
was it was exactly that and this is
actually kind of the scene of that game
i briefly spoke about when we were
comparing notes on you know the most
memory memorable game you sort of won
out of the opening
through very good opening prep right
this is actually
what happened in my game against uh
grayshook in mexico city
that i won uh with the help of uh the
the model of analysis but uh i didn't
play uh all of this is very very well
known knight f3 check looks like a
stunning move but
is still very much in existence and this
is what they do now and you for as you
can see on your screen there there's
very very high profile games which
reached even this position but i took on
f3 with the queen uh which used to be
the main line but i think that actually
was
analyzed to an absolute draw
you can play queen takes f3 bishop takes
c3 queen king g1 here
and then the game continued between a4
check
knight c2 bishop takes b2 and we have to
play rook c1
and i did win that game kind of
convincingly but yeah as i mentioned
like since uh you know the advent of
stronger computers and just generally
after
you know uh alexander motel and myself
we sort of introduced this into the
public consciousness right people people
did spend some time analyzing it
properly and i believe it no longer
really promises anything to white at all
which is why gf has been chosen theory
marches on yes so gf uh we now have to
play queen g2 uh kingitu would be a good
move not for the fact that it loses the
queen you can actually make a bit of an
argument for doing this with white takes
takes rook d1 take on d6 if we can right
but the king only two is very awkward so
i would assume that queen yeah at the
very least black has an immediate
perpetual queen b2 uh rookie two queen
b5 and you have to play king e1 queen b1
rook g1 queen before and we're kind of
going in circles actually maybe this is
not a perpetual we we actually save the
g6 pawn that way right king e1 yeah
check from b1 right knight g1 doesn't
look right but if you play rook d1 after
queen before check we can no longer uh
uh
attack the queen while parrying the
check yeah black so
this doesn't matter
which is why white goes uh queen g2 uh
queen takes a191 queen g4 here is the
main move we this position was reached
uh for instance in the game between uh
anushkiri and mvl
uh bishop g3 very very
big names there yeah
hate giving up the bishop like that we
have to give up something uh and also
let's let's go one one step back looks
like 95 is just a straight up horrible
blunder of queen in one move right right
after let's say bishop g6 check
but very acutely black can just ignore
it if you take on six you do lose it
yeah there there goes the queen yeah but
you can you can just straight up ignore
it play king e7 and maintain your your
fork on f3
which gives you a very good game very
nice so what white is choosing here
after knight f5 what what what issues in
between is a position with the bishop
pair but with the queens coming off the
board
or giving up one of your bishop pair but
keeping the queens on
and as we see in the game linear very
clearly prefers keeping the queens on
because i think uh
if you count with if you count material
here white has four pawns against six so
if the queens come off it's a position
with sort of a material balance but with
the with the black king no longer really
having to worry about any kind of
attacks once the queens are out yeah the
queens are over the y structure is
broken up the bishops aren't as powerful
just yet
but with the queen's on then the
question is where is black gonna put his
king yeah you can keep it in the center
but eventually like white will play king
jituruki 193 and in the center i think
the black king will look very very shaky
so i think if it goes anywhere it
probably goes towards c8b8 but even
there then
with the half open b file even though
there will
uh rook so king f1
and again i'm going to just ask
alejandro uh in this lanier versus
farouza what's the winning percentages
don't tell me all the games ended up in
a draw
it's not such a huge sample size from
particular this position we only have
two games at least in my database i'm
going to have to ask varuge if he's able
to find more but from the ones i have
one looks like a 2300 game that ended in
a draw and the higher rated game is
between uh wei yi with the white pieces
against liu chang lei two very strong
chinese grand masters in 2020 and that
one ended in a draw as well both of
those games followed with the move
castles in this position so it's more or
less what i expect uh but the engine's
saying you could also castle the other
way and just try to hide the king on b8
i am a little bit afraid for black's
position in a practical sense because i
like white's plan of putting the king on
g2 uh securing the pawn on f3 going
knight e3 putting the rook into action
and then trying to attack black's king
doesn't matter where it goes even in a
move like castles the engine's thinking
that you can start with the move h4 yeah
bishop b2 is the more natural move i
don't like king g2 as much because after
queen f4 again this plan off as you guys
said removing the queens right you
attacked the pawn on f3 i don't really
want to tether my queen to defending
this so
i like to move bishop e2 against castles
and then try to follow up with a very
quick h4 or queen d3 and penetrate on
the light squares i still think there's
problems for black to solve and already
i think got to this position must be
very well aware of it because they spend
pretty much no time to get here
but it might just be the start of the
nearest file
yeah absolutely it does look like a very
you know heavy duty uh contest of uh of
analysis on
on both sides but
another uh very heavy duty piece of
analysis theoretical battle taking shape
here between shaq and napo i'm aware
that the theory in this particular line
of the nimzo the classic variation
queensy 2 has been extended peter it's
unbelievable
how deep uh the players are prepared yes
and uh somewhat sadly for us the line
that they're debating uh right this
moment is
uh extremely well known
and also has like it's very very strong
drawing tendencies it's been sort of
analyzed into dust
i wouldn't really be able to
name every single uh move order
intricacy here but you generally do end
up with the position that they ended up
with uh right right now eg7 you include
fghg you take on d7 yeah they all look
similar but i think it's bishop takes c3
not knight takes c3 no this one also
exists right this is uh bishop f5 bishop
takes c3 and uh there's been a there's
been a bunch of games i think even we
covered a decent number of those which
white occasionally
gets a bit of pressure i think i've seen
uh yeah yeah that's the game if we if we
scroll a little bit further down in the
game list i think mvl won this on the
one yeah this is the game i was trying
to remember and vl actually won this
against anish geary in 2020
uh but most of the others and this is
very very high level stuff there's a
game between mvl and ding liran
which i think is from the feeder
candidates in the first part of the
feeder candidates in uh i i
inadvertently clicked something yeah but
this is the end game i was referring to
you basically get some kind of an end
game like this
and occasionally you still win it yeah
and mvl actually did win this against uh
against anish
even though it looks even though it
looks like from the beginning i have a
feeling anish at first
just thought mvl wants to just check how
good his memory is on the day and offer
a draw right this did not happen and vl
continued pressing the bishop on b3 is
stronger than the bishop on c5 and
eventually the pawns on the king side
start rolling and it starts
you can start seeing an outline of how
you can go wrong with black
and anish in that game actually did end
up going quite badly wrong and losing
uh so it's a kind of a nice little free
roll for white quite obviously at no
point runs any risks whatsoever but you
generally should not be winning very
many of those
it sure looks uh
tepid to me but alejandro
what have you got for us we have three
games in which they're going deep deep
into theory we have favi and levon
already in an end game dominguez and
ferruja and this wild sicilian you guys
already mentioned this nimzo indian
between mamet and nepo and this one is
quite the opposite players are going
very slowly it's mvl against hans neiman
it started with knight f3 and we've seen
mvl once in a while start to venture
outside of e4 especially in the recent
years he did play d4 as he mentioned in
the candidates he plays knight f3 once
in a while to throw off his opponents he
is not this one-dimensional chess player
that he used to be now after knight f3
d5 g3 they took a little bit of uh of a
while to get to this position i think
they were trying to test each other how
exactly you're going to follow it up and
we have this reverse groove fold
position after c takes knight takes
bishop g7 c4 and in this position
castles takes takes and the move knight
b3 now knight c3 is still the main line
in the position uh this has been tried
many times knight takes pawn takes we
are familiar with this structure we've
seen it in the in tournament before
between wesley saw and the von eronian
the structure that is not the exact
position the idea is that you shatter
these pawns with the idea of opening the
b file using the advantage of this
bishop on a b7 so a slight initiative
for the white side but of course in the
long term these pawns are quite weak
instead maxim's chosen chooses the move
knight b3 it has been played many times
before including by maxine himself he
defeated wei yi in 2019 so at this point
he might still be well versed in this
position there's a couple of lines here
for black there's nothing wrong with
knight b6 but it does go into the
symmetrical position down a tempo you're
still going to have to equalize it e6 is
quite normal in this position and people
have even tried the move knight before
simply with the idea that well if you
take take knight c2 wins an exchange and
otherwise then the knight might retreat
to c6 and try to cover up this bishop
it's a little on the uncomfortable side
but it does put a concrete solution to
some of black's problems so this will be
a long game knight v3 currently on the
board hans thinking for a little bit
not the usual mvl theoretical fight yeah
i mean it's still a very very well
recognizable position as you mentioned
knight c3 is the best move but knight c3
these days i would suggest is sort of a
draw for because after knight c3bc3
there has been
a kind of well-established ways of
equalizing almost entirely by force both
queen a5 and even the immediate 96 is
quite playable
uh queen a5 in particular i think is
what i give in
uh in all of my greenfield courses
starting from the the old one
uh in in 2013 2014 that i recorded for
uh for chess 24 and i think this got
progressed to the the chestable course
as well 93 is a much more serious move
here and the one that
uh i think is sort of at the forefront
of white's tries okay uh to achieve
something after e6 i have a feeling what
will happen is the move h2h4 which i
myself played age against vichy
and i don't know like maybe
it's kind of a weird one because uh i
got introduced to the existence of this
move uh when we were playing training
games against gary
and and gary showed me this idea and i
kind of barely equalized and then a few
a few months after that i just suddenly
got this against vichy on the white side
it was very surprised to you know
happily introduced for development and
practice and uh i had a bit of a pull in
that game but as is often the case with
my games against vicious explain yeah it
goes yeah it did not get very far no i
actually have like one or two victories
against visually in shorter time
controls i'm it's just a classical that
is completely hopeless
uh
so after e6 i think i think h4 is you
recommend e6 by the way for i i i felt
from from the black side i felt that e6
is the most kind of precise way to
player is the most critical way to play
because if you don't remove the knight
from the from the g5 square it makes it
much much harder for white to play
knight b1 c3 right it also somewhat
limits the bishop one g2 as you're
indicating so we're trying to play
knight c6 let's say on a b6 bishop a6 in
an ideal scenario or
queen e7 rook g8 and we are trying to uh
continue yeah continue asking why so
what are you doing about this knight on
d5 what is your what is your way of
dealing with it and h4 interestingly is
an attempt to answer this exact question
because you you kind of want to play h5
of course and if 96 you also have this
idea of playing bishop g5
oh bishop yeah this is an additional
thing that exists once you've played h4
of course provoking f6 is going to be in
our favor because it closes down the
bishop on g7 right and if the queen goes
somewhere like if you play queen b6 for
instance
you can play knight c3 here and uh start
kind of gambiting gambiting some pawns
here because the bishop on g5 followed
up with eventually with h5h6 ideas
will be interesting we also are now
controlling the g8 square for the rogue
we've lured the queen to perhaps uh not
the most ideal square on the board
bishop d7 is now not really very easily
playable if the g file gets opened if
the d5 knight departs i mean so there's
this idea there's also some other ideas
of the queen b6 uh so all of this i
think makes uh makes h4 extremely
playable
wow it shouldn't really give white any
particular advantage necessarily but
it's definitely
it should lead to a position which is uh
interesting to explore and definitely
not very boring at all
definitely not boring i just wanted to
make a quick check yeah this is quite
stunning yeah i think one actually
remembers
because something tells me
alejandro you actually got to this
position when we were talking about the
pawn sacrifice yeah so it seems that
they know exactly what they're doing
levon
and fabi they had they did work a little
bit together in the olympia as levon
mentioned yesterday but i don't think
they went down these entirely that would
be i think they got there independently
yeah i think i think it's just something
that doesn't happen like if they
actually looked at this together no i
would assign like a zero probability of
them ever discussing it over the board
right uh because there is like an
unspoken code about these things exactly
exactly you you work on a line together
you don't just suddenly expose it to the
whole world like look at our great
homework and make a draw now on the
other hand again black maintains his
pawn but you have to wonder why it's
supposed to be better here right like
white is down upon black has a potential
outside passer on the h file
uh but because of the active king the
activity
um
i'm still not sure trying i'm still not
sure why we're supposed to be better
here with white to be honest like i mean
you only need to queen one punch
i know but it's not really running very
far even guessing it through c6 is not
that easy the way the pieces are and
yeah
yeah and the perfect square is it yeah
so yeah i'm curious
i'm curious i understand that for black
like you can play h5h4 but pushing that
pawn further than h4 will become
difficult because g5 is
potentially creating weaknesses and uh
but
still it's a it's a pawn right
like but also can i maybe i'm interested
in the idea of maybe activating my rook
but a6 is a valuable valuable point i
don't know i i don't want to depart with
that guy i don't i don't know how happy
i would be by uh with i mean if you're
going to make these races you better
calculate them very
uh exactly so
um
give me evaluation you know the
evaluation zero zero zero zero zero
a bunch of zeros yes uh there's a couple
of ways to play here for black according
to the engine yes h4 is one
just
push it a little bit further i expect
fire we'll reply this with c5 bishop d6
is one way to get a zero but i don't
think that
that you're playing for this rook end
game i think you're playing c5 and the
idea is that it's still not so easy to
advance these pawns on this side
remember that the moment that you play
this move bishop c3 comes very strongly
because rook h6 is a devastating threat
just check meeting on h8 and bishop f6
targeting all the pawns might also be a
problem you also kind of start to run
out of activity uh
kingy forking f5 will also become an
idea here and i think that's why fabi
put the king on d3 so quickly another
way of playing this is to just shed that
pawn go rook the a check and ask where
the king is going to go if it goes
towards the center you could go give
another check if it goes
otherwise you could still play a move
like h4 and the computer says that takes
you can still play rookie a check and
give checks in this way and since it's
an engine it just thinks it's zeros now
i think this is a scary position for
both sides for white the idea is just to
play c5 move the rook somewhere and go
c6 and even though it looks very slow
especially with the bishop on h2 already
controlling c7
it is really slow to actually push the
pawns on the king side because the
moment that you do so you give me
avenues for the rook to go behind them
you give avenue for the bishop to
relocate to a better diagonal and more
importantly you're exposing your king it
doesn't look like your king can become
too weak in this end game but it is the
king doesn't have any defense against
bishop c3 rook h6 the moment the g pawn
marches all the way down to g5 so yes
technically it's a draw if you put this
into engines and i'm sure that they
equalize it in more than one way but
still work to be done and i think for
both players
um
let me
let me just uh take a toss out uh in
this position black goes f6 king h7 and
says f6 here yeah yeah yeah c5 you might
be king king h7
or king f7 yeah you wanted to go to h7
no no f7 sorry if someone's fine i think
yeah i was just gonna try to bring my
king into the game it's not so easy to
bring him in though rook b6 rook b6
you could go to g6 according to the
engine but i don't think that was
direction you want yeah well king g6 oh
h4 i don't even know h4 and then how how
are you pushing this pawn yeah that was
the argument that was very slow slowly
but i'll get there you know i'll play c6
i'll play rook b7 and one day i'll play
king d5 bishop d6
it'll come
i mean you haven't created a pass spawn
yet okay g5 g5 let's go bishop c3 and
you're instantly lost so no maybe not g5
maybe not g5 yeah
you can't go g chief yeah i think that
you know g6 okay go ahead king g6 but i
think i got c6 here right okay king of
five king f5 i go rogue b7 g5 finally g5
i got king d5
suddenly this button is not so slow well
the bishop on h2
alejandra announced he will play bishop
d6 right well i'm about to play rook d h
seven
not to try sticking back yeah this is
sort of the point here they're against
37 then we play bishop d6 and eventually
it will start costing you like material
real real material and the the variation
the variation there on on the screen
behind behind that still of course says
uh says zeros but you can you can start
seeing sort of the outlines once again
the outlines of how this can go wrong
and the the lines that gives it as zeros
like the second line there i think will
eventually result in black having to
give up the rook actually
i'm reading i'm reading the the letters
right king g4 right bishop d6
again no rook d8 because rook d7 right
takes takes king g3 c7 already training
rook beard which is a queen
rook c8 only move i could take i could
play rook b8 this might be lost for
white though i'd be very scared king
takes g2 remember i have a pawn too i
have you have the eight pawn as well i
have the eight points you go hey five
you go h3
king b7
h2 rkh8 now which is
so it's a long end game and lava's
already played the move rook d8 check
i'm actually curious about this one
particularly because king e4
and because of the configuration of
these pieces just particularly in this
position i don't think you can go king
d5
yeah because of rookie 5 check and if i
start
if i'm being forced to play king d4 and
i allow rookie 2 this is suddenly not a
slow pawn right this is a very fast pawn
so i don't think you can go forward
rookie check maybe you do have to go
i don't know king d4 looks awkward
because rookie two is the same position
so i think we can never allow rookie too
yeah so i maybe what what do you answer
rook d a check with
can you go king e4 rookie 8 king f3
king f3 that would be an idea and just
stop these guys right right the engine
doesn't the engine starts to think black
might be pushing for a little bit wow
still thinks it's equal but it starts to
think of moves even like rook e6 yeah
rookie six is playable bishop g1 a kind
of a cute little move bishop g1 with
ideas of grief
someone's running this maybe g5 yeah
perhaps actually rook takes a6 g5 yeah
and we go for like mating threats vertex
e6 g5 of course zero zero after bishop
d2
yeah well black yeah it's like it's
extraordinary this is not opening theory
anymore you guys are looking deep into
an ending i mean
and the crazy part is since the opening
this is something that he's trying to
achieve
this is move 35 he has 92 minutes on the
clock so 92 minutes yeah so i mean fabi
clearly is still in the book and
honestly left on his you know meager 18
80 minutes left from 90 beginning you
know even even left could very very
easily still be in book or
nearby yeah well i suspect uh pardon me
let me just uh bring that up
and i suspect all the way up to here he
still is because yeah i mean that whole
a5 business he basically
he made one small pause along the way
just to make sure he remembers
everything correctly right and up until
now he's been pretty much blitzing so
yeah it does feel
it does feel like they both have a
pretty clear idea of what they're aiming
for and honestly i'm a little bit scared
for this game because it feels that fabi
is now thinking
and from what we've seen on our screens
on alejandro's screen in particular it
really does feel that maybe you kind of
have to take a repetition at some point
because king seats yeah
yeah king c2 i'm a bit worried about
rook g4 or g4
specifically king c2 i'm i'm a bit
worried you you might be provoking black
to actually play for a win but like king
e4 okay king g3 i'm sorry yeah i think
if we want to really restrict the rook i
think this is the way to restrict but
and that does invite the rookie six yeah
but i'm not sure if the bishop ending is
better for black at all because um c5 c6
i don't know maybe maybe it's well i
think white steel doesn't risk very much
because even king of seven king e8 we we
stopped the c pawn quite comfortably and
it is like generally bishop endings with
an extra pawn aren't really that
horrible
uh
so
yeah all of this all of this is kind of
confusing because
this is what i began with i don't quite
understand why white is supposed to be
better right
but uh perhaps it's it's just like if i
we wanted to check whether livon
ever analyzed rook uh
king c2 properly instead of king bisou
because king vito of course he knew he
would be playing against a very well
opponent but quincy too is rare but
seems like homework had been done
at some point i i'm still amusing over
uh
playing a bishop name
extra pond can't be all bad
and also once again i also just did want
to check the game of nepa for just a
moment because yeah this is yeah this is
this the anisha the mvl game yes this is
still this is looks so even steven yeah
i'm amazed that mvl could
uh beat a top player like anish from
this ending i think as i mentioned i
think uh this line at some point uh was
almost exclusively used by the the the
players with the white pieces as a way
to
you know
very briefly check whether you mix up
some more orchestra and then offer a
draw and i think anish kind of labored
under that misapprehension for the first
half of the game that he was just
sort of expecting some kind of
repetition or the rooks coming off the
board or something
and
you know by the time he realized that
mvl actually means to continue yeah his
position deteriorated and it became
difficult but yeah it should be it
should be very level to begin with well
again i'm seeing two games here that for
me this game of shack
and the game of fabi are
extraordinarily deep
opening analysis that are
really as we can see and games
linear versus
[Laughter]
127 after move 26 yeah 127. which is a
very very clear indication today today
is really like a very very heavy duty
theory day the only game that is
developing somewhat slowly and without
too much
uh
of those is the uh the mvl hans game
okay well hans actually chose knight
before hans didn't choose e6 and we have
this position where um
the knights are for why the knights are
on b3 and c3 and knight c3 was very
quickly replied to with knight hc6
really doesn't look horrible at all for
black sometimes these types of positions
end up not being
all that pleasant but this really
doesn't look bad at all well just a
second here because
isn't this knight going to be driven to
this
bad square or sure maybe it jumps to
[ __ ] like if you play a three here
that's actually you have to at least
consider queen juventus knight sister
right aha because oops excuse me that
was of course a mouse slip
queen takes the queen takes d1 we have
to take with the rook
you have to play rook b1 because
p6 is poor
for her
oops so yes so
and then the knight can uh kind of sneak
its way first of all there but also i
want to like maybe postpone it for a
tempo just go bishop five here suggests
that maybe we're not also knight takes a
three was available even on the previous
move but i think bishop five might be
stronger
because white is actually kind of facing
slightly uncomfortable questions here
right because 94 is uh annoying that the
xa3 will continue being annoying and so
on
uh
so
maybe a3 is a bit naive okay if we make
some very pathetic uh move in order to
just drive drive drive this night yeah i
mean your general uh first idea or that
we badly want to play two a3 as early as
possible to push a really horrible
square on a6 was absolutely correct of
course yeah
um yeah bishop f5 here or or somehow
yeah how annoying again the a2 a3 gets
delayed because of bishop c2 probably
going to have yeah see well we have some
masters game which reached this position
as well so this is not unheard of bishop
d2 by the way played by mvl
any i think weirdly for a position which
i think looks quite
quiet right quite quiet not not really
very much going on yet right i think it
becomes incredibly concrete because if
yes if we achieve a three knight a6
i think we are suddenly significantly
better right
so black needs to do something about it
straight away like you
you want to maybe prepare to retreat it
to c6 like you play i don't know i can
see on my screen that somebody played
1965 here for instance knight c6 e5 yeah
just to give a square yeah give a square
and also knight c4 is kind of heavily
indicated as right if white does nothing
about it exactly uh yeah and uh a friend
of the friend of the show mark hepton
played this in uh in 2016. ah a big
shout out to uh two friends of the show
your friends at the show the friends of
the show yes
[Music]
some olympics olympiads i played with
mark hampton uh jump in on this one
alejandro uh we're trying
to go down yet another rabbit hole and
what does the
winning percentages
say about this position for the players
there's a couple of wins here and there
specifically after the move rook c8 i
only have three games in the database
and it split one win for white one win
for black one draw
all three results are possible all three
is possible i suppose that being said
there is a little bit of a rating
difference in the one that black won
black was actually uh the underdog by
200 points they won
uh and this position in particular after
rook c8 it does seem like it's time
finally to play them with a3 nothing
wrong with it knight a6 has to be played
and the question is what did you really
gain from misplacing my knight on a6 it
does look like it's awkward but it will
return it will go to c7 and e6 if you
don't do anything in particular uh you
can also just play b3 and control this
knight on b3 saying this knight if i
ever get the move b6 in is this knight
on b3 is just as useless as this knight
on a6 yes so why why is white really
better the enders are very impressed
with this particular version of the
groomfield they say it's pretty much
zero zero so
i want to see exactly what mvl has
planned because in the meantime we could
potentially just watch the ending of the
game between shah and yam because shaft
today was not in the mood to torture in
that end game and we are
going to uh to have this conclude very
very quickly uh bishops of opposite
color it seems like that for shock today
this really was a memory test and he
wasn't
too interested in trying to win what i'm
pretty sure from the beginning is like a
nothing burger for
for white
okay uh draw agreed in uh this
uh so first result of round seven um
i don't know whenever i see these grand
master draws where as you say it's a bit
of a memory test
it's not the most exciting thing in the
world but
we've had shaq here uh i think that was
around uh
two did he lose in round one i'm it was
either round two around three right he
just uh we haven't seen him since even
though it was a great interview he lost
round two to hunts right yeah so that
was round three i said yeah he had drawn
with fabi
fabi makes great preparation mamidarov
makes great defense well that was that
was later no the the point i was trying
to bring up is that uh
he he was in our studio the day after he
lost that painful game to hans and he
said i generally if i lose a game i try
to play the next day safely because i
like i don't like the feeling of having
just lost and i
i like to kind of stop
stem the bleeding as early as possible
exactly so i think this is what we've
watched today like
he seems to be pretty consistent in
uh you know taking a a game off if he
loses if he loses a painful one and he
definitely lost the painful one
yesterday he sure you know uh arguably
that was like a full a full one point
swing in one game right because he went
from i mean calling his vision winning
probably is a bit of an overstatement
but he was clearly much better
and yeah he he straight up lost the game
to a resignation in six moves flat yeah
which yeah by his standards
his play from like move 28 22 to move 28
was like absolutely beyond the pale
true um
turning to the game of lanier uh versus
ali reza we've seen bishop e2
pardon me we see castles bishop e2
justice alejandro was explaining and
white is desperately looking to activate
his pieces knight e3 h4 on tap knight
could swing and maybe uh go after the
king
seems to me that as black we might uh be
interested in posting up our rook on f4
maybe maybe yeah with some different
idea like rookie four queen d4 ideas but
the white queen has a decent square on
c2 if all of that happens right yes
um maybe even immediately and one thing
i want to make uh
kind of uh
note for our viewers here is that
you know maybe uh at first glance you
might think the king on g8 is sort of a
better position than the king on f1
but in fact the kingdom fund is entirely
safe right it's got kind of a nice
shield yeah because this this shield
with a bishop on it in particular
defending the f3 pawn and black not
really having with black only having the
heavy pieces
like if the king gets to g2 it can
pretty much never be attacked by
anything because you know there's no
cocoon yeah there's there's no there's
no knight f4 check no knight h4 check to
even look forward to in the future for
black so right uh the white king on g2
is completely safer as the king on g8
you can definitely imagine scenarios
where it it gets into some trouble if
white starts you're bringing bringing
his pieces over to the king's side right
which is i think the reason why the
machines perhaps
prefer this a little bit for white not
not by the time i'm just thinking that
castles is actually a novelty here
castle short it was i think alejandro
was saying it that the machines very
much indicate casting is entirely
playable okay but we are
we are going to have our first interview
of the day uh
the game may not have been very much but
the the interview could be we'll we'll
see inaudible could be outstanding yes
alejandro is with uh yanubomnich it's a
lot of pressure guys
here we are with you on a solid day at
the office and nothing much to prove is
that what you felt
well uh i'd say it's like my more or
less you know one could argue but it's
like fourth game and they're always the
same
very i would say boring scenario yeah so
basically
it's like uh okay the first of the first
day i lost but this game you know
doesn't count second day i won then okay
it was
an awful game against linear but i
managed to drew and then it's like four
games which uh
i mean basically they could happen like
i don't know in in every tournament like
every time control but it like was all
quite a boring draw
so like for example today it's like a
theoretical draw uh i can okay i can
understand shakhria is not like
in
probably was not in a mood you know you
know what to challenge i mean you know
in any principled line so that's quite
understandably having like okay this uh
not the perfect score but um yeah also i
had feelings like yes for example
yesterday was
yeah like fabiano
uh picked the line which is not very you
know doesn't suit him too too well and
no no not really the line you don't
really expect from him yes like
uh trying to make a draw in a worse
position without a pawn okay
i mean we
we both know it's a draw but i would
expect you know this line from rapport
against whom i played the game yeah
but rapport didn't keem but he's opening
did he
yeah
i don't know what to say so well of
course it's a little bit frustrating but
still throw two more games hopefully
we know that you're a fighting player
does it bother you to make this kind of
draws
uh
i would say uh
i have nothing no no problem
you know no no problems at all with the
you know with the sequence of draws
but the problem is most likely my
perhaps
okay
uh one cannot be sure but perhaps my
last tournament in classical before
before the match yet because i'm not
seeing like i'm being invited somewhere
like twice on there or something
uh so yeah that's a little bit
unfortunate but uh yeah maybe you know
when you play unless you train more yeah
so that's kind of cool uh the match is
still pretty far away have you been
given any kind of more or less dates
no not really so it's uh okay they say
it's april may so probably uh the second
half of april okay perfect uh did you
know there's a punishment for people
that finish too early
sure yes
you have to come here and analyze that
now
okay
tell us a little bit about what your
thoughts are your greenfield player uh
it seems like in this particular
position
the engines think it's zero zero do you
think that there's any possibility for
pressure beware of using engine yeah yes
yeah
well
i thought that's all it was always
critical like to play an mb5 instead of
uh
did you see this not not be free and
this position might be fine but you know
when you have uh like
petr swiddler you know
in the commentators
yeah maybe it's a little bit
you know too much to ask me like as a
griffin expert
especially since i'm not playing
greenfield for quite some time but yeah
this is the line i played for so many
times
i think for for both particularly
particularly
bishop c8 right
but uh i think after bishop v6 fight
also can you know can try different
things again 93 is just playable
so the surely what benefits maxim in
this position that's like it's the
greenfield from the both colors here so
yes symmetrical greenfield and perhaps
he has slightly better experience here
but yeah okay this knight only sixes
looks a little bit misplaced
and if
you know if black won't want to do
something quickly about it it would be
just
slowly you know get worse and worse
because okay you okay you say three pawn
and a seven pawn i think like especially
in the symmetrical structure with uh
quite some you know time advantage i
mean tempe advantage for white it's it
could be quite something here so the
position maybe is
far from from being trivial but
i would say it's quite unpleasant for
black is as as a as what i see now
okay uh
white black just played them with bishop
e6 we have the move queen c2 seems to be
a novelty it seems like the only games
that got here did go knight d2 queen c2
seems very logical to me however
um
queen c2 is like you don't trade off the
queens here right just try to yeah i
mean the question the question has to be
if they play bishop five here do we go
bishop before like what's right
well surely i think it it's between like
okay queen d2 is not
i mean i'm not sure queen d2 is
improvement comparing to queen d1 yes
exactly i can't even english pc
experience to trade the queens here so
yeah bishop before is logical okay
sometimes also 94 would would take you
know
it's probably not as bad like 94 because
94 think we'd be free it's get me take
here and then no no i mean immediately
94 immediately
ah here okay some some tricks here
coming that's the knight a5 they put 90
for queen defeating ig5 is yeah surely
the move which would be found in a
second yeah
sure uh yeah so okay bishop before but
uh well sometimes you just uh have to
you know to say goodbye to this uh you
know catalan griffith bishop yeah but uh
instead of this you're getting all these
like brilliant uh
this is yeah like i mean ever every
piece from white is active and rugby one
is coming so this is yeah rook d1 is
coming queen in the center
really nice yeah by the way by the way
it's like it's a big difference a big
difference in how like the queens are
placed so like queen only forest road is
like
arguably the most dominant square for
the queen yeah and a structure right
uh tell us a little bit are you familiar
with this and yeah at least i played
against leffen blitz uh i mean it is
chess com blitz championship song
championship or something
and uh i really thought this is like
some some sort of throwaway prep because
it's uh no i mean i didn't know what to
play against burundi so i decided to
play these explain to our audience what
does it mean a throwaway prep i mean
probably
the prep you don't really expect too
much of here
so even if it works like like here yeah
clearly uh fabiano is more or less in
still in his book
but she don't really achieve something
yeah so in the i think in this
particular line it's only only one move
which black has to know is a5
because if not e5 it's i mean i think
black has different tries but somehow a5
like is very smart position in yellow
you're like
white never plays for two connected pop
best pawns yeah yeah because you
immediately yeah and you exchange it
okay after ba six b6 i'm i can i can
recall like i was analyzing this
position i was like sort of excited as
well like finally we have something
against this d5 first berlinia which is
uh you know quite annoying so for
example like
you get let's say italian type structure
if black is not going for g5 but d5 is
more or less a try to make it draw by
force
which uh however as far as i know for
the current situation is not refuted yes
not yet and okay this was one of the
tries and i played against him uh the
line and i think i think against him
maybe i got slightly better position but
thank you some
maybe a blundered rook or a pawn or a
bishop
so that's a pretty different drawback of
playing some you know some prep in this
tournament yeah especially online we
don't have blitz uh games here uh how
did the game go was it exactly this
variation all the way to a5 yeah oh no
no i think it was like king c2 for sure
maybe maybe if i can be true there are
two moves basically king city and king
b2
so here if someone has chest bass or i
don't know someone like that a bit
surely you would you would find this
we'll take a look or uh yeah or maybe
maybe search that like
we got peter on it uh and then we only
have one game left
do dabble on the night or give us your
thoughts on this position uh
i think it's used to be quite a line
which probably petroleum against you
know again peter himself played this
against grishok i think but yeah yeah we
discussed it and but it was like 2001
2007. something like that but
i don't know queen f3 right
yeah okay
i mean okay it's
it's very difficult you know to surprise
uh linear even with some you know very
very old sequence of most and okay this
idea i think i think it also was played
like grishouk i mean nakamura played
this against shook in some moscow grand
prix right
2017 i think a very good memory yes yeah
because i played there and played
miserably
of course because uh
only thing i had only thing was left for
me is like
you know witness other players yeah in
well you're starting learning yeah but
uh
yeah because okay i think i also i was
played against icaru and uh he didn't go
for this line against me he played some
bishop g5
so
well i i don't know clearly
so they finally started you know to
think right well
hasn't he's spent only a couple of
minutes but he doesn't bless out i would
say a little bit you know reminds me of
the line which
alireza played against me in madrid
because
objectively the line is good and
computer approves you know
stamp yeah computer props
but his position collapsed no quickly
it's very it's very i mean humanly it's
for in my opinion yeah i mean even here
yeah it's slightly slightly slightly
easier to play as white because i mean
okay you always have two pieces and you
have your you know your your goal is
quite clear and of course like if we you
know remove the queens it's
when we say the goal is quite clear
remember we have a big audience oh okay
uh give a mate very good very good very
good
they say that that's that's the way to
win each other a game of chess here yes
so here okay the king is exposed and as
for me i would not i would not be sure
that much about you know castling
kingside up on queenside i would say
that probably
you know queen side to me would be more
logical because then you can come up
with something i don't know h5
h5 g4 but maybe it's like the same
problem because okay rook b1 and white
quickly
yeah you know quickly brings all the
pieces into something like this knight
e3 rugby yeah so probably the position
is all right for black yeah you know
mathematically but uh
once again uh
when you're out of your book okay when
your knowledge is
uh you can probably can your position
until maybe the castle or something can
hear okay probably okay you can make a
couple of phones like rookie f4 okay
fade i mean okay very very helpful
errors here and white plays king g2
queen d3 yeah okay
you see i can um
i can only play by by reading the errors
yeah but yeah okay now it says for
example h4
no but it does very smart yes very smart
no
it's it's very it's very i mean easy for
white so you just with every next move
you create another thread and that's how
you basically deal with this position
because of course if like if black gets
his time like uh
makes sure okay the king is secure like
uh i don't know
uh
takes like some key squares from white
hair and by moving deep one or maybe
okay creating some passive pawn on on a
queen side we just saw i mean already in
an analytics scenario then okay then
like surely like has an upper hand but
for now it's like very very concrete
position and what dwight wants is like
yeah all right well just open up open up
things and i found what happens yeah on
the topic of the italian i found if it's
only one game you played against lev
you you did indeed kind of blunder upon
at the very very beginning
because
the game i found did not even feature 95
g5 there's a game where young played
king c2 instead of knight takes e5 there
oh yeah probably probably yeah because
uh yeah maybe i thought uh
but i will say that blunder maybe
transpose yeah knight c4 bishop c1
bishop takes f2 and the game continued
from there well it definitely has
compensation here but no i mean this is
this is somehow this is somehow better
for white i can recall but yeah i think
in case of if he would to take on f2
it's just i mean a draw which is
i thought okay if black knows e5 it's
relatively simple but
yeah well yeah thank you for all that
analysis though certainly covered the
games we have left uh i hope that we see
some great chess coming up in the next
two rounds
i hope so thank you thank you all right
guys thank you yan for uh taking over
our job i like it i love it i love it i
mean get him on the show more often by
the way peter i mean seriously i just
have to say
it's extraordinary his knowledge
of all of these positions i mean
including the
fobby game including his own
the farouza is like you give him a
position he says yeah yeah yeah i
analyze this in moscow this is how we do
it yeah i mean
i think it's been very very noticeable
in in in recent times just how much uh
jan is
working on chess there's been a very
very market difference in in
the attitude towards the game the
approach to working on the game i think
you know this is why he's playing a
second world championship much in uh in
as many years because he is just a very
very serious
uh chess player in terms of you know the
work ethic of the attitude i mean
we've we've been talking about this on
the show but absolutely the fact that he
kind of knows how to play chess in
general has been known for quite some
time well yeah his knowledge but also
just i mean his extraordinary knowledge
of the opening and again it's just
familiarity uh
with the positions by the way yeah this
is quite interesting for me because i
didn't like this
rook defores what you rejected because
just like this yeah you're kind of
compelling
uh levon to play for a win and and with
goodreads i mean alejandro there was no
compelling he could have repeated he
could have yeah but like lev as well is
not having a particularly stellar
tournament so you know given half a
chance
he will very happily play a game of
chess and yeah like rook default looks
like a suddenly a very interesting game
of chess for black right i'm not sure
i'm not sure i'm that interested with
white to be honest like what am i
supposed to do here why am i not worse i
mean alejandro was harping that hey wait
a minute this h-pawn is actually pretty
fast
but peter uh
following the nepo interview i wanted to
ask you what's uh q boutique let's take
a break
first
yeah today's uh today's item from the
queue boutique is this uh
chess club t-shirt with a st louis chess
club
logo uh
on the front there available i assume in
a variety of colors and both as you know
men's and women's fashion uh they do
wear very nicely i have a not exactly
like this but generally uh some of the
swag that the club provides i i wear
very very represent people that's what
it's all about very very very good
they're they're comfy t-shirts and are
we getting a discount what's the story
on that why why don't people
[Laughter]
uh
we're going to take a break and we'll
see on the other side
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of bank
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched
to learn more about the st louis chess
campus visit stl stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to round seven of the
sinkfield cup with one game concluded in
the round with three others all looking
fairly promising in terms of
potential results and just general
intrigue and here's the draw that you're
talking about
shaq and nepo had a very theoretical
discussion peter went right into this
ending that's drawn they've made a draw
now we've also seen another uh
theoretically
hard-fought game between fabi and lavon
but
that's not
that my free result yeah that might yet
end in a draw but uh five definitely
made a choice uh i thought was
questionable yes
and uh
as we were going on the break
in order to
uh vacate the premises so let's begin to
get to the sort of the general lounge
area right you do pass through the the
the smart board and on alejandro's
screen there after king c2 the move that
uh that five [ __ ] shows instead of
let's say going king e4 which i think
was a pretty comfortable draw there for
him yes uh he went back to situ
allowing this move rook g4 which i
pointed out was definitely a potentially
promising try for uh for black and
already at this point uh the only move
that
is supposed to be holding is the one
that fabi made so it's
very clearly is playing reasonably well
today he sees things quite
uh quite cleanly and he is not
mathematically worse yet but you can
definitely like you you'd be a bit
worried here with white wouldn't you
because
is a constant problem right in
particular if the pawn on c4 disappears
because then like let's just imagine a
position of source like rook takes a6
all right just to demonstrate to take c4
king b3 okay we go rogue g4 let's say i
don't know rook c6
all right just making yeah
we take on g2 yeah and after a6 we have
bishop g1
okay
and
these types of positions like
here for instance perhaps bishop c5 is
just completely fine for white you still
have to calculate and perhaps all of
this works out
but
if if there is no immediate solution for
white uh
the the best you at some point start
hoping for is to perhaps win the bishop
for the a pawn
but then there is three runners on the
other side of the board and the king is
on b3 very very far away from the action
meaning that the pastors probably
actually win that race quite comfortably
you don't want that rook versus three if
you will right because i mean the
understanding is that let's say if the
white king is in front of the pawns the
three pawns i don't think they win
against the bishop when when the bishop
defends properly
but with the king on all the way on the
other side of the board i think you're
just kind of lost which raises the
question for me uh do i need the c4 pawn
as much as i need the g2 pawn
and in other words after rook takes a6b
yeah the reason i was saying all of
those things is that let's say we go
rook c6 here you take on g2 right i go
with the check yeah
it is a very very important that it's a
check but then once you play bishop g1 i
have c5 right okay and that breaks the
connection between the bishop and uh and
the pawn of course if you're a girl yeah
of course
if it's a girl and your girl is faster
which it appears to be here maybe black
is just winning it's a very kind of a
weird position a7 h1 right with the two
rooks actually you know in the way
blocking the diagonal for both queens
but after h7 there are no sensible
checks
uh yeah you can maybe this is maybe
steal the draw somehow it's weird it's
weird i i'm not suggesting that i would
want to play this with either
the color right but it is a weird uh
line i just didn't know if i needed this
absolutely yeah yeah
it's a very valid point i thought maybe
it was more important to remove an
additional blocker for the
a7 yeah but it's very possible that
you're right and the fact that we take
on g2 with a full tempo right a full
additional tempo because it's a check is
just more relevant but what i will say
is that
what looked like a very safe game for
fabi he was above his starting time by
move 30 all of this was blitzed out
including them of king g3 right is now
definitely a position you can imagine
ending
in any of the three results yeah right
so this is a very welcome change for us
as viewers
uh maximum
is by the way i thought mvl
got something yes i think it's uh i
think i like what hans has done just on
the previous move not king h7 that's not
very not very exceptional but playing
knight c5 without taking on d4 might be
an important detail because if you if
you do it the other way i think maybe
the logical way you uh
start by calculating is to take they can
play knight c5 here yeah because you're
creating a threat of knight b3 right and
you also would very much like to play
knight c5 e4 next next move awesome and
continue trading exactly but we came to
the conclusion we're discussing with
that with a hundred on the break that 95
might be extremely painful here
ideas of queen ticks
yeah and also using the fact that knight
e4 here which will probably be okay it's
probably met by queen takes c8 the game
doesn't end because you have king g7
there after the rook takes right but the
suspicion is the very strong suspicion
that you wrote that it's not good or
something like that d8 might be
borderline winning yeah like rookie 8
queen e5 e3
yeah and then if you play e6 i will put
the knight on f4 and be a happy game
yeah and i feel like i'm giving mate
here somewhere right yeah this really
does feel like i'm probably giving me
because i seem to have more pieces on
the board like it's it's three fighting
against two it doesn't matter what
they're called you know it's just three
fighting against two and you do uh he
didn't take on dean he played knight c5
a move that you like
takes takes and now if white goes 95 we
do have knight e4 because there's no
yeah the king is already on g7 so there
are no forks on the e7 square
does it mean that i'm gonna have to
vacate uh the c file well there is still
might be three yeah
but yeah if the queen's come off it's
not that that's horrible right no it'd
be three queen g5 cringey six no i need
i need uh i need to be smarter
rook d5 94 yeah
i'm not so sure yeah well
it looks promising and yeah the pawn on
the five will be kind of bothering black
for for the foreseeable future i don't
know if this is best play but it
definitely makes sense for for mvl what
should we play there alejandro alejandro
well let's start with the fact that
envio might have left
uh let hans a little bit off the hook
we can go back to this position after
queen e6 takes takes oh he could still
have played knight d5 couldn't he yeah
he could have played knight d5
immediately and i think that would have
been a little bit stronger in this
position you're still using the fact
that this rook on sierra is hanging so
for example if you play i don't know i
think knight d4 is one of them here
knight takes d4 works but also just to
illustrate the point that queen takes c8
will just finish the game you can't take
twice because at the end of the day you
have this fork knight takes e7 attacks
both pieces and it doesn't really matter
which direction this knight on c6 go so
after knight d5 you just can't move the
knight
and if you can't move the knight i don't
have like an immediate threat except for
queen takes f5 uh no quick sorry queen
x5 is not an immediate threat because
there's an item c6 still but what do you
do with black rook fd8 i think is why he
didn't play it i'm pretty sure rook the
fda but then you retreat with the knight
on f4 and this knight is actually pretty
powerful it might not have like queen e4
exactly yeah and this was kind of the
key uh rook d3 was what the engines
wanted to do and it's a very clever move
because if you take on d3 here i can
actually take with the pawn
it's counterintuitive and it's difficult
to see from afar but the more you
analyze it you realize the queen doesn't
have too many squares it actually kind
of has to go to a4 if you go to e5 i'll
just go d4 if you go to a4 i go d4
anyway remember you don't have any
possibility of moving the knight because
the rook is under attack and what is
happening this knight is very weak queen
takes f5 is coming this is a direct
threat and white is just tactically
better in every complication so you
don't hold on too easily to
black's position instead in the position
that we have in the game rook d5 already
played 94 absolutely forced and already
on the board
white still retains a pull you still
have better pieces but there's no knight
on a6 bottom knife is not hanging
there's no direct d4 d5 type of threat
the other uh situation had so you can
still play queen d3 and claim an edge uh
the idea of queen d3 is just to start
getting off of the c file so you can
finally this knight on e4 also queen d4
check might pick up a pawn someday so
it's a nice maneuver of the queen but it
doesn't have the strength of the other
position the engine is thinking that
black is not fully equal
but is in a position that's quite
survivable at the moment i i thought
there was something else actually
because i realized if we can just go
back a couple of moves after uh knight
c5 for me like bishop d4 knight c5 yes
can we go knight g5 here
this has an issue after this you take
take and you play knight b3 and now the
problem is that if you take on c8 like
in the other variations sure takes rook
takes the problem is that after i play
king g7 i mean everything is hanging i'm
actually hitting both rooks and the only
way to coordinate them is this way but
that drops the knight so okay so that
actually will apply to the other line as
well yeah this is what we are like a
continued blundering knight b3 yeah
because i was suggesting 95 in the other
position as well and it's the same it's
actually the same line right
okay so yeah uh that means that
at least some of what we were discussing
earlier makes no sense but
that's very usual for this show nobody
nobody's going to get phased by that
clarifying that is very very very
important knight e4 and by the way i
mean uh my hair stood out on on end when
alejandra said queen d4 check might win
a pawn i thought wow okay um not for a
while yeah i kind of like this though
for for for white yeah you should it's
just not a huge advantage but i think
it's clearly the open file yeah control
it's one of those positions i don't know
how much better white is but i never
take black over white in this particular
position yeah
just because they're that they're i mean
this pawn is a little weakness there are
checks rookie yeah but the pieces pieces
are going to continue coming off the
board black can play something like i
don't know rook c6 here try to play rock
six rook fca just get get his pieces
into the game okay it feels like it's
not very much of course you prefer white
hair because white you know has the
activity has the slightly better pieces
different has the safer king
but
a lot of pieces have gotten traded off
already and more are probably coming off
the board right in the immediate future
so my feeling is
uh black should be able to maintain
equality here if he plays well okay but
of course you can still you can still
imagine this going wrong for for hans
okay and
then i just wanted to bring in the
lanier game because lanier played this
whole
king f1 bishop each five minutes already
yes and then suddenly after the most
logical move rooksy yeah
yeah i mean
that this move had to be the the most
topical
uh discussion points right absolutely
and then at 25 minutes and yeah already
already 25 minutes in uh
uh in the tank
counting down he will be below below the
one hour mark pretty soon i don't think
he he looks necessarily like somebody
who's going to make a move anytime soon
exactly we've seen this roman year time
and time again we're very used to this
picture extremely well prepared always
ready to debate you know the most
topical the most critical lines
uh lines of all and uh
and then the moment somebody plays
something that is perhaps not first line
yeah
uh stop it yeah a stoppage and a very
very deep uh you know an attempt to get
to
the truth properly because lanier i
think doesn't do things in halves in
that in that respect he really wants to
you know investigate and and get to uh
to the answers and yeah he might well
spend another i don't know 15 minutes
here okay but here's a
more practical question for you peter
and look at this position as white and
there's three moves i really like i like
93 i mean 93 just getting off the first
rank bringing
maybe just throwing it out there that
hey my knight could end up on g4 i could
fork your queen i could fork your pawn
so i really like the move knight g4 i
really like the move h4 the rook on h1
you know press him into service open up
the h file let's get going and finally
and most obviously i could put my king
and tuck it away so i've got
three very promising over the three i
don't really like king do i think that's
lowest on your
uh
because
yeah because i think ng2 sort of gets in
the way of our own play here a little
bit because if we want to play h4 with
the king on g2 we will not for instance
be at least not immediately threatening
h g5 at all because of queen because we
absolutely do not want any end games
here the queens absolutely have to stay
on the board because if the queens come
off
we're fighting for equality and probably
we're fighting in vain frankly i don't
think they're equalizing uh so i think
the king on f1 where it cannot be
checked by anything it should stay on f1
and between 93 and h4
my current preference is for h4 because
i think it's more concrete okay and once
again perhaps we will be you know i can
imagine definitely some scenarios where
the idea of winning an uh an additional
tempo by playing hg rg1 for instance
yeah might be useful uh which tonight on
e3 would get in the way of okay but yeah
the choice between knight e3 and uh and
h4 is not an easy one for me and uh this
is just a gut feeling i haven't really
tried to calculate very much it's very
difficult because we're not really
creating threats that are
uh you know instantly very very you know
frightening for black yeah the apollo g5
will be covered by rook four eventually
i would assume so it's not that horrible
uh and it's it's not easy to uh to
calculate at all what's going on here so
i was i was trying to kind of eyeball it
and
so you sign weights yeah yeah me too and
the idea was uh king g2 you would weight
it as as the least
because of the possibility that queen
takes g5 i'm sure it's better than
and also you might want to use the g
file if you ever get it in http g1 so
that's
understandable knight e3 versus h4 h4
that might be the harder this one is
difficult harder choice to make i think
also something that is sort of
instinctively driving me away from
knight e3 is the fact that
like we're giving some additional
squares from which black can maybe offer
queen trades it's currently not very
critical because quincy three queen
takes g6 but if if black plays g6 g5
here foreign h4 okay we've basically
lost the game to queen c3 i mean lost
the game is strong but the queens will
come off yeah and once again i'm
extremely extremely scared of endgames
here with white i feel like my position
cannot support an end game okay so i
don't really like relinquishing control
over the c3 square because currently as
things stand right now the queen of d2
is quite safe the only square from which
it can be really kind of challenged is a
four and one screen of four happened
then i will happily play knight e3 and
get in the way of it right not to
mention or queen d3 or d3 but not until
that you don't want to see queen c3 i
don't i don't want i don't have to
calculate it even though as i mentioned
it's probably not fast enough now
we did that and i beg your pardon we did
that in three to five minutes uh
you made a very compelling argument
in my mind that the move h3h4 is the
most precise
why is it taking them so long to reach
the same conclusions this is a twenty
thirty minute thing i think you know we
are he's not on uh
a superficial you know um super
i resemble that remark just a second
you're resembling i resemble every mark
and i said done sir
h4 let's get on with business alejandro
what's the problem
h4 why is linear
stewing over this decision is it so
difficult well we didn't mention the
best move
oh the best move is queen d3
and the point is that in many cases
having this queen g6 available against
queen c3 is important now it's not like
queen g6 is going to be a devastating
threat uh in most cases because black is
going to play something and most natural
moves defend against it but i was going
through some of the variations that
maybe they weren't so logical like for
example i thought king g7 right sure why
not right now instantly bad problem is
that after h4 h takes g5 is such a
strong threat and you don't have a good
way to recapture you take with the queen
i pin you with rook g1 you take with the
pawn thank you for the h7 square you
don't have a good way to do this and you
don't want to take on h4 it's just
structurally bad so
all right let's say you don't have uh
king g7 you could play rook c7 and try
to bring a rook that way then we
continue with h4 and the engines are
just saying that because you always have
queen g6 and you're not as weird of
queen c3 you basically gain the tempo so
you're gonna be able to play h4 in a
nicer way now
the engine's top moves are rook f7 kind
of get that you cover the seventh rack
maybe king f8 is possible at some point
also good enough for your quality king
f7
whoa not sure about this one but if you
let the engine run for a little bit it
starts to think yeah i know it starts on
plus one but it starts to go down and
down and down on evaluation thinking
that the king on f7 maybe running to the
center in some cases it's just fine it
which is completely counterintuitive
because you just castled now after rook
c8 if you play h4 which is a very good
move the edges are pretty adamant about
the move rook f4 uh it
gains the d4 square for the queen again
offering that queen trade and it blocks
out many possibilities of coming to the
king side now taking on h4 i'm not sure
is an idea but just in case let's say
you take you take back of course with
the pawn if you play knight e3 i'll go
queen d4 and then you're gonna start
chasing my queen around
because queen is for example here queen
d3 here here what sorry and of queen d3
there after hgh yeah quick
queen d3 in this position then we play
rook h4 and it's a kind of a similar
scenario
you you are so happy as black to shed
some pieces that it's okay if you lose a
pawn as long as all you want is to
retain equality so you kind of give up
this pawn on uh
on h4 i think i'm going to be able to
capture it with chuck somehow i think i
can even do it right away
and the engine is just not through i can
take right yes
but the engine is just not thrilled rook
h8 starts
controlling your position rook h1 is
going to be apparently a tactical
problem so
this is just not that good for the white
side it's very deep i mean i'm not
surprised actually that linear is
thinking so long because h4 queen d3
even a move king g2 need to be
considered and there are so many
ramifications going from every move now
there is partially
that point and partially the fact that
he's just linear yes
he just does this it doesn't really
matter which position he's on
but you compil you compile both i'm not
surprised that he's gone what a must be
by this point a 30 minute thing yeah it
has to be it has to be around increasing
it's important oh
yeah it's it's like 35-ish by this point
yeah and by the way uh alejandro in that
variation you showed where black was
playing rook h4 was it necessary to take
on h4 could we have gone queen g6 and
rook g1 like for example h4 rook f4
hghg
um queen d3 i think we had rook h4 yeah
you can play like this and then you want
to play rook g1 yeah the problem is that
it's not so clear at some point who's
attacking who because i have rooks you
want in this position now again i don't
want to trade queens but if you take on
g5 with the rook i have rook h1 check
and again king g2 is just me right right
on h nice so now you have to trade i
trade you i have to take with the
you have to take with the queen because
if i take with the king i trade the
again i trade the queens
so i have to mention e2 is hanging too
yeah oh h6 yeah you you're not hanging
the bishop right you have queen h6
taking the rook exactly but if you take
with the king i just trade the queens
and if you take with the queen here then
black's attack is apparently more
powerful than whites actually that's not
so surprising with your queen
very nicely
make any sense yeah you start going
queen d5 you start attacking this knight
and it's all play in one goal black is
definitely better in this position so
that's the thing as soon as i play the
move h4 and the rooks come in and i
think that's why he's played rook c8
that's why the move rook e4 is very
natural you're trying to create counter
play against this guy this king on f1 if
i can get him through the c1 square or
get him through the h1 square that's
going to be very powerful for the black
side you have to do this very precisely
for white to avoid the rooks coming in
thank you very much for that uh ali
hogan queen d3 quite the lesson for me
because
i was
so focused i must say peter on the
um
immediate h4 as well as the immediate
knight e3 i really didn't appreciate it
once you start breaking it down it makes
a lot of sense
a lot of sense and i think specifically
we are playing against this idea of
rooker 4 rook h4 by trying to right you
know prevent the rook from landing on a
fork comfortably because at the very
least it will cause black and h6 pawn
with check here if you play rooker 4
here and ignore queen 6 check
in what alejandro was telling us by the
way one of the real
surprises for me was king f7 yeah
i understand you want to protect the g6
square but king f7 stepping into the way
of the rook
wasn't a natural move for me not at all
and yeah very interesting development in
the uh carolina ironian game because uh
5g take on a6 black did take on c4 rg4
did not end up being played there
interestingly after e36 and even more
interestingly the rook did not go to g4
here either
wow
meaning that
white now gets a bit of a free pass
right with uh
with his uh initiative on the queen side
but one thing the move rook c1 does do
yes
is
it stops
very very convincingly the idea of rook
six bishop c5 right that is true it's
not even specifically six it's just that
once the bishop gail goes to g1 here for
he he's not you're not worried about the
a-bahn
winning a rook yeah it does control that
diagonal so well that yes a6 a7 might
still cost us a bishop in some scenarios
but those positions will pretty much
always be at least a draw for black
because the phone on g2 will never
survive check king h7 yeah like a6
bishop juwan here exactly this is
extremely safe for black
nice uh i i don't know if black can be
better but it feels like it's extremely
unlikely black can be worse here
and a very good point yeah in hans's
game uh after uh rook g594
queen g3 hans did play rook c6 and here
uh yeah unveil made a very concrete move
rook cd1 hoping perhaps that the
weakness on f5 will allow him some kind
of an initiative and you can take on f5
now but black does win the ball on c3
straight away so let's take a look at
this so take case i guess we give a
check from d4 and black i guess plays f7
f6 nothing else makes any sense to me
and
if we can find something immediate here
for white we could be a bit better but
the black king
it generally probably just drops back to
h8
and then you claim and then you claim
that it's not really
nothing that misplaced strikes
sorry rook g5 chad quinto x3 yeah
okay so we have to play king of seven
the king of fate here let's say f7 right
uh but then start with rook g5 don't
start with queen d4
oh that's much stronger wait up wait up
wait up uh let's start with rook g5
check sorry g5 and if king f6
we probably have some kind of a yeah
like queen takes h7 king takes g5 f4
check probably some kind of man it might
not even have to be fancy even queen d2
must be winning yeah but this might also
be quite strong right like
uh he said queen d2 yeah just go just
drop it back to g2 and create threats
this looks horrible for black so after
it takes a five we might have to
wait with the capture for a move and go
like maybe f6
or maybe rook g6 rogue six might not be
stupid actually rogue d6 just trying to
trade some pieces and then pick up on c3
that looks that looks playable very very
very very it looks playable playable
because we pretty much have to go rogue
do we rook definitely i don't do yeah we
might even we might as well have to play
yeah because i'm just going to get it in
a drawing
yeah i thought i can go rg5 check
but what it does i think is just bring
the king closer because i think we can
like we can actually rub it in and go
king of six
[Laughter]
considering how much is hanging on the
white side i think we can do that right
here a muhammad agar is willing to
sacrifice the rook on g5 now i'm
sacrificing the rook on d1 with chad as
well that's a little much yeah i think
i've overdone it there a little bit
okay
so
546 probably is just completely fine as
far as we can tell alejandro stop us at
any point if we start spouting too much
all right i'll go through the lines with
you uh
we have this position r5 rook d6 forced
yep uh rook g5 is possible of course at
any point i can just go rogue d5 and
claim the draw right check on here only
one move in this position king kh6 is no
good
rook h7 rook h5 takes check here check
king goes to f6
check here check can't go to f6 because
queen g5 checkmate here
check
king f5
check
can't take on e4 because the after
mentioned uh queen h5 no g4 g4 wins
sorry g4 just means the queen in this
particular position
forced because this loses the queen so
i'd rather lose a rook and the engine is
saying of course plus one
of course of course so king h6 is no
good because of this plus one situation
you have to go here the other way so
that you don't have this rook h5 you
could still play rook d5 and claim a
draw or you could take and here you can
do this this you you don't have to take
but you don't you
i don't think anybody plays rook g1
check so king takes g5 f4 only move king
f6 we go back to the sequence check here
check again no king f6 because queen g5
checkmate king before check here and the
initiative has run out you have to make
a perpetual queen h5 king e4 queen f3
and that's why you see mvl in that pose
of extreme concentration because he's
probably calculating he's probably
calculating all of this yeah and in the
meantime uh linear had a firewood
yeah
actually emerged emerged from the very
very long thing there with the move h3h4
which is not a bad move as we know but
uh
according to the engines yeah
it only took him
i wanted to say i i want to say 35
minutes maybe 14. yeah okay let me let
me check exactly so uh queen d3 you
think is the utmost accuracy h4 good
move
uh
just maybe
not the best
i just wanted to ask in this game
between lanier and farrugia
was the move castles uh by black on move
25 was that the novelty
alejandro
in this uh the novelty of this game was
because it was immediately after castles
that bar feel free to jump in at any
moment
no my database stops at 25 like after
move 25 it just doesn't right it was
move castles that uh did it for us as
well no no but i mean it's like it was
it didn't matter if it's a novelty or
not it just doesn't have a database
after 25. i'll get you
did it like a novelty
did that short castle this one they say
it's a novelty this particular move h4
oh okay so uh everything up to up until
now has been i'm assuming played in a
correspondence game some games something
like that and the correspondence people
probably did not miss queen d3 which is
why h4 is a novel i see yeah this is
this is how i think you uh you approach
these types of deductive reasoning yeah
um so h4 played
um and we're expecting rook for in yeah
should be extremely logical here it just
makes sense on every single count
creates the idea of queen d4 as
alejandro very importantly mentioned
also creates that additional possibility
of
you know dealing with the threats along
the h file by pushing the rook on h4
right it just feels very very logical to
play rooker for him
certainly and once again mvl
um
and we'll play c3 c4 okay so he is
trying to prevent from the rook from
landing on d6 if
if hans takes on c4 here and vl will
just take on f5 quite happily and rookie
six is no longer a move you can make
exactly you can play f7 f6 though i
guess right to start g5 checks
and after h5 if all else fails we have
queen e4
or rookie for but i think probably queen
e4 more than looking for right so
yeah rookie for rookie fall looks very
very briefly maybe
exactly for yeah but definitely clears
the cobwebs yeah
in fact
maybe it's even playable straight away
after rook c4 rook five
i feel like we're running some
additional risks perhaps but maybe if we
if we're if we're actually still forcing
a trade maybe i can i can start with it
like just
go queen here
rook g5 check yep
i want a tracking of six months again
like i have a feeling that with a queen
on e4 we're almost never going to be
getting anywhere near mated
it just controls the board so well that
uh yeah and i think i think the ball on
c4 got picked up since already yeah yeah
we do have rook takes c4 and yeah by the
reach it looks like he's planning to go
queenie four yeah that looked like a
gesture yeah yeah there you have it on
your screen yeah q4 played by by hans i
think uh yeah my current understanding
is this is just fine for black because i
can't really figure out how to keep the
queens on the board and if the queens
come off this is just a very very level
rook ending i don't think anybody is
better there exactly no it's just the
fact that you're missing yeah you put
the missing the g pawn you put a pawn on
g6 you're probably
slightly better
it's like just one of those there's
temporary glitches that if the queens
stay on the board yeah but your people
is just extremely precise yeah if white
had a way of keeping
um the initiative the attacking uh
rook c2 queen d5 no rookie 2 is going to
cover everything no you're just
frustrated as well yeah exactly it
doesn't really matter much nothing is
happening so yeah it feels like hans uh
you know there was a very specific
moment i think somewhere around move
19 where mvl could have played in a more
critical fashion
specifically 95 instead of 94. i think
94 was extremely uh extremely natural
and
you know what i get the feeling that mvl
missed knight b3
i get the feeling that unveiled wanted
to play 95 in your in a position on your
analysis board and he thought it was
working
and i think it's it's not working over
yeah bishop d4 rook g4 and then knight
b3 hitting too many and i think this is
missable i think this is a kind of a
tactic which
you hopefully don't miss entirely right
but you can miss sort of from slightly
far away yeah and then you realize that
yes you've achieved this very very
advantageous trade
but then you have no follow-up because
every single piece of yours hangs
including this room yeah this is this
room and if you and this gc4
there goes the knight
wow yeah so that would be maybe my guess
because if 95 did work tactically it
would be a just a very strong move i
think which potentially offers white
a significant advantage that's kind of
like a strange trinity there you only
have three pieces on the board and every
single one of them seems to be under
captured
peter like well done and uh well
once
they reached
94 it looks like hans yeah i think hans
is pretty much pretty much out of the
woods or out of the woods i wouldn't say
control but yes lavon
uh
yeah bishop c3 is an interesting choice
there by fabiano uh
saying basically that
he doesn't believe that rook g1 is a
threat
okay because i suspect you know once
again something like rooji one rook this
route 6 isn't playable though
but we can go i guess rookie 8 and then
a6 a7 right
so rg1 we go check
check king h7
right we go a6 and if you do take on g2
i think a7 actually queens that pawn
right because we have rook hi check
exactly so bishop g1 seems like for a
second that player
has everything just had time to no but
unfortunately not with the kha yeah so
you can't go rg1 which is why uh levon
for now has gone king h7 stepping away
from rook here so now rookie does not
win a tempo for white right and just
generally getting your king off of the
back rank is is always going to be
something that is quite useful no
question about it yeah
and also keeping for the moment you know
once you play rook g1 you can't play
bishop g1 but uh keeping the g
one square vacant this looks perfectly
fine for lavon and again uh i would say
three results peter i mean it's just i
think draw is still sort of
favored heavily favored yeah yeah
because i think the apon does end up
costing us a piece but then we go after
the g2 pawn and we uh well again let's
just put a move or two down on the board
for just a second if i go like this
sorry a6 mission g1 r7 for instance
right exactly
perhaps hinting that in some positions i
will be interested in bishop d4 let's
see if maybe even in this position d4
here
yeah oh i'm not entirely sure it's
playable but maybe it is who knows sorry
maybe
bishop d4 here
oh
yeah i mean it changes my outlook i must
say well i'm not sure i'm not sure it's
that great because i think if we just
take on d4 and go king h5 for instance
and i will just defend from the back
rank like a7 looks eight right
not you can you can you can place your
rook behind right but then you will have
to spend like 75 moves getting your king
to b7 in the meantime i will organize
passers on the king side i will never
ever be worse in those position numbers
yeah i think it makes a very good uh
uh it makes a very good uh point that
you're just playing passively and yeah
but because your king is so active yeah
i don't think you're running any race i
don't think i run any race whatsoever
here we've had uh simply an
extraordinary uh number of events that
have been taking place here at the st
louis uh chess club uh
from the whole summer i don't even want
to say spring
uh to the summer but still we've got
more events coming up peter let's take a
look at the
upcoming events yeah uh once this is
done the 12th potentially will feature a
tie break and will definitely feature a
closing ceremony for the sinkhole cup
on the 13th there is going to be a bit
of a banter
counter face-off yes and exactly team
rex and team uh somebody to be declared
yeah right right be determined uh but
ultimate moves is over he's a fan
favorite even has been for a very long
time bring your best trash that would be
a very very good fisher on the movie
best russian
trash talker you ever ran up against
i think jan probably would be
good
would be good
yeah
some people like
it very much depends on whether like you
mean on purpose or by accident right
because there is a purpose there is
there are some names there who uh are
pretty decent at it without trying and
other examples and i don't like vladis
has some like there are some stories
about vladislav yeah but the the thing
about those stories is
i think in many of them he's doing this
earnestly like his
it's uh
it it might be you know in this
particular case might be a disqualifying
factor yeah like it's a it's kind of a
tricky one um but i'm just thinking
about recruiting you know some serious
trash talking something to look forward
to think about i think sasha would be
good as well like yeah i think i think
there's a nice nice
we're going to take a break we'll see
you on the other side
stay tuned
[Music]
in 1839 the university of missouri is
steeped in tradition the recently
founded mizzou chess program is a
partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
by now you guys probably know there's a
lot to see and do in st louis but when
it comes to the art scene
there's more here than meets the eye
from lao meyer sculpture park and the
city garden to the stunning cathedral
basilica one of the largest mosaic
collections in the entire world
so if art is your thing
st louis is on display all year long
ooh
now that's an exhibit
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
that's our show now go plan yourself.com
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the st louis
chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the team's inception slu
obtained second best university at the
pan american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round seven of the
sinkhole cup where we have one game
already finished and three three others
are very much still in play but it does
feel like
action is slowing down a little bit
absolutely would be a fair way to
describe it
a lot of very important theoretical
discussions here
in particular
in the years between dominguez uh and
feroza and the uh karana iranian clash
very very interesting very topical
discussions being being held
but uh it seems like alireza now is
going to
be reasonably safe here
uh it's it's a line that we were
discussing uh i think perhaps even with
uh no i think jan has already left by
that point but that was a line that
alejandro was showing right
uh
the the point here from the black side
is you will lose probably both h6 and h4
pawns right uh but
uh white has traded away all of the well
not all but most of the potential
attackers exactly meaning that the
resulting positions such as this one
uh after rook h8 like i think the xh4 is
actually unplayable here as far as i
understood alejandro i think you have to
play queen h7 check first because here
after queen h4k uh
you are fighting for equality with white
rock h1 check being an extremely strong
threat
uh so i think we give a check from h7
first
after queen takes h6 checking f7 f7
queen
yeah we do this and then uh black has a
number of things to consider like you
can probably play king g7 you can also
queen g7 yeah i think g7 is probably
what we do yeah queen g7 queen takes h4
and the difference being that now after
kh8 white has an additional check from
f4
but i think we're probably still doing
that with black and just playing king e7
here
and
uh
king e1 appears to be maybe i mean king
e1 on bishop d3 whichever one you like
best because rook h1 check is coming
right it's impossible to stop
but as we keep on harping on about like
even if black does something here which
i don't think they should which is rook
h1 check okay k2 and queen e5 check i
don't think this is necessary
but the amount of material left on the
board here i think pretty much
guarantees black is not worse
uh despite the fact that we've
voluntarily spoiling our structure in
the center
yeah you're really trying to make a
point maybe a little bit of overreach
but oh yeah that's your point i get you
i think four against three with the
white people with the white pawns
spoiled as they are i don't think we
pretty much ever win uh win this with
white so yeah i think black is just safe
okay i think alireza should not be
losing this uh this game and then as we
were coming on air uh
we were
slightly debating the mbl position where
am i with mvo here we are
uh
actually they went for a slightly
different version of what i was
expecting yeah it was sort of what i
expected
and uh hans they're showing a a very
sort of decent understanding of what's
in front of him by really forcing this
end game and forcing it with a trade on
f6 as well where
as we've i think discussed even or
during this broadcast this is a very
very sturdy setup absolutely and in fact
an argument has been made i think it's
actually a very well established
argument let's say we play rook c3 here
yeah
and white takes on a5 yeah it's
preferable to have the structure on the
king side the way it is compared to f7
g6 and h7 it's remarkable yeah the first
type of the first time you see this
argument it might kind of strike you as
being completely ridiculous right but
you are controlling sort of more squares
this way your king is safer the pawn
breaks are harder to achieve and so on
exactly but obviously of course nobody
gave me
the a5
that that quick but that was viktor
korchner teaching me that in a three
versus two the doubled f pawns were the
best and i was like
confused and
well let's just say i i argued the point
until
it was very well made and then i stopped
arguing the point by the way once again
i find today's round most especially
a little disconcerting in the sense that
i found the
opening preparation of the players to be
of such a
a caliber that
it was like they they just went from the
opening to the end game to today was i
think
the
the first real demonstration of what uh
elite chess can sometimes be obviously
not every day because we've been
watching this tournament this is round
seven and in the first six rounds we saw
glimpses of this but not
really such such an
you know acute demonstration and game of
the game of the game as we as we do
today exactly uh of people
clearly demonstrating
very very deep knowledge of the same
lines it's not like somebody is
surprising
their opponent and then at least one of
them is thinking yeah well uh we were we
were passing ships grand master ludic
bachmann of the czech republic
czechoslovakia at the time and myself
and he was a very very well-known
theoretician and he would go around
shaking his head and saying after one d4
there's no play
that's kind of what i'm feeling like a
great theoretical play
uh in this round alejandro but uh
for all of their
greatest efforts um
don't i'm not expecting many results
doesn't seem like it this one is
definitely going into a draw we'll see
if lanier chooses to continue the game
like i think actually tell the rest of
us continuing the game he's actually
gone queen takes h6 check and instead of
what i expected king f7 he's actually
running the king away so queen h4 check
i think is just planning on meeting with
king d7 i assume this is the point which
also feels relatively safe i think once
the king gets to hide behind these pawns
should be fine i don't think you can
fully escape a perpetual but i also
don't think you're going to have much
more than that i just don't think you're
going to win with this construction
again you needed that rook
to deliver checkmate
but now that there is no rook it's very
hard for white to organize any kind of
checkmate
you're never forced to trade queens as
white in this position so you'll never
do it so what probably will happen is
that you find some kind of repetition
some kind of perpetual and there's not
much to do about it and lastly in this
game between levon and fabio are
actually fighting against levon
we still have this complicated end game
where still a lot of things could go
wrong the thing is like i've been trying
to go wrong with why either side
and it's just like no matter which
variation we take
both sides are just in time to make a
draw it doesn't actually matter like for
example in this position rook g1
rook takes f7 is somehow a draw i was
trying to make king g6 work still a draw
if you play bishop g1 and just shoot the
rook away you finally start trying to
lose but most
normal moves in this position i think
just make a draw so
again a lot of interest a lot of theory
but you said it yasser might not see the
decisive results exactly we were looking
at uh king g6 i believe yeah i thought
u6 was by far by far the most natural
move but bishop g one and give up the
piece
this is what i would be trying to do
with black if i were to try and play
this for a win but i assume the the apon
just runs
uh quickly enough in the meantime
there is a little bit of a discussion in
that rook ending just to finish because
yes the game will either continue for a
while or perhaps kind of end straight
straight here somewhere
so white is
sort of pretending that you can blinking
a forking a five
and then perhaps there will be some
sukswangs because like if you kind of
naively play three let's say
i'm king of 482 okay can i go king of
five here i get
no exactly
probably still a draw perhaps after rook
h1 right but specifically after rook h1
because we're kind of running out of
moves here a little bit right i lost h5
instead right yeah yeah we could
actually try try h4h5 try to lose the
tempo here i was kind of worried that
after h5 king h7 king f5 king g7 we
don't get the
rook anywhere yeah i'm i don't know i'm
being i'm being stupid yeah just rook k3
here right this is the thing is one the
thing is it's still a draw even if we
win the a2 pawn as we've established
like completely yes
we want rugby five check here i'm not
losing this vision right but we did lose
the a pawn right
and it's important you jettison that
pawn and not one of them
yeah
but
there there must be a i assume a way to
to make that draw more comfortably
somehow uh and this is why hans is uh
thinking because um
you know given a choice he would much
rather not have to not have to suffer
here in a three against four exactly
no matter how drawn it is like there's
if there's a way not to subject yourself
to it why subject yourself right yeah i
i would think that i would just like i
would prefer to try to tie you down yes
to this spoke of three and and then your
life should become easier it's something
something this once again
takes a three weeks
one here
king of four
a2
and now with the pawns not on the second
king f5 always get gets met by rook
therefore
i think that's the construction we want
yeah i think this is what we would like
and we do have rook what do we have let
me just refresh my board yeah and i
think unsettled on something like this
and they appear to be repeating yeah h5
check already played and han says yeah
very clearly not playing a382 until he's
good and ready exactly which is how it
should be here exactly
king of four played so yeah well uh nvl
not repeating just yet but it feels like
uh he will rook a2 f3
okay one yeah king f5 should not really
be like
too much right mm-hmm
nice in fact
now now we can see we can still play two
here and then either rook found a rookie
one depending on which one you move and
actually 4k one loses here right a kind
of a very picturesque position here you
can you can you can lose it with in one
move here with whiteboard playing e4 and
suddenly realizing this is you don't see
this checkmate every day that is a
rather
uh self-help mate uh if i i've ever seen
one very much so
i love uh studies by the way i enjoy
puzzles but these self-help
self-mates have never appealed to me it
felt like i was doing something
anti-chess yeah even though
the genre exists but they they never
really you know
caught my fancy too also it also doesn't
really feel that interesting right yeah
studies like proper studies
in particular you know some of the best
ones which really do look like a snippet
from an actual game those can be
unbelievably beautiful exactly uh
completely and now they are repeating i
think we can sort of stay with the over
with the overhead view because it's not
really going to continue for much longer
from here
and we all decided not even to play f3
but if you're not playing f3 or you're
not really asking very many pertinent
questions right all the controversies
aside how would you rank
a hanza's play i mean
from a rating perspective he's played it
at like a 2700 yeah he played he played
absolutely absolutely fine you know some
games are better than others like he
obviously i think his first three games
are a great start very very impressive
arguably maybe three and a half because
i think
his approach in the opening yesterday
reza was very good and then he quite
clearly went slightly kind of astray
because like
as he was explaining to us during the
press conference here the interview not
really the press conference
he was he you know became very attracted
by that calculation of people that that
very beautiful uh double exchange
sacrifice with roon g4 and when that
didn't work
uh i think you know his residual feeling
that i must always be better here kind
of almost almost kind of led him into
trouble right at the very end right he
he he waved alejandro away there a
little bit but he was at some point
potentially significantly worse in that
game right it wasn't all
as safe as
as perhaps could be
okay by the way
just uh
something interesting has happened in
the game of fabi and lavonne
when we left it we were just
alejandra didn't mention that this
exists right you want to take g2 a6 has
already been played we just played
bishop g1 here of course allowing
anything allowing the the pawn to reach
a7 right would be
unwise egregious
yeah and i guess y just goes a7 and and
holds this very comfortably i don't
think white has any kind of specific
trouble here no uh a7 which play seven
rook a7 and black can play h3h2 or black
can play king h6 and try to
join the passers and uh
yeah but it's two two pretty much never
wins against the bishop even if the king
is this far away
yeah hp5 here and after h2 i think the
cleanest is just to take on g7 and then
to take on h2 right ah yeah versus
bishop yeah i don't really even want to
think about that rook ending
i feel like
exactly exactly i don't want i don't
want to
touch that rock ending but this is the
this is the professional uh
this one is not very interesting no
and that would definitely shut it down
bishop g1 on the board just a second
right here yeah instead of a seven white
can make some other moves but it doesn't
really with the ball already being well
i mean if i'm trying for this i'm
looking at
this and i'm getting scared and also i
mean the rook will come to a2 in
previous positions when we were trying
to trade bishops the rook had no way to
get to the a file exactly if you're
providing rook with a very clear path
towards the a file none of those
quote-unquote winning attempts do
anything exactly so yeah i think you
just go a7 here like you double check
that h3h2 doesn't actually win
for black but it doesn't so so you go
away seven and the game probably ends in
the draw very good exactly
all right very good and i'm going to
throw it over to you alejandro as i do
see farouza marching
he's taking a king walk across the board
um is this a
is the young man playing for a result
i think they're still playing chess
let's put it that way but as in many
cases the favorite is a draw the reason
is that the moment the queens get traded
in this position black starts to taking
a good look at a win
a little bit more material any end game
in which you can create a passport on
the queen side might be dangerous as far
as two pieces bishop and knight don't
always coordinate very well when you
don't have a good anchor square for the
night and there is none on the position
so you don't really you don't want at
all to trade queens with white
meanwhile how does black really create
threats you only have a rook and a queen
which means that whatever you attack
it's going to be counter-attacking and
be protected by the queen on h4
it's hard to imagine that either side
makes real progress in this position
there's just not enough threats there's
not enough counter play maybe you can
argue that black wants to go for the a2
pawn but where's white's ideas if you go
f4 f5 it's not going to do very much
because by that point the king is
already going to run all the way to the
queen side so still a game it's not a
draw still a game but i i i do think
that draw is favorite yeah
absolutely and yeah that feels fair yeah
that feels that feels entirely fair uh
peter just on that note of that game by
the way though i mean
if you were absolutely forced to pick a
side
that you would like i prefer to play
this with black i think i think it's
easier to imagine how blacks make black
makes progress than how white makes
progress because you know perhaps in
some ideal scenario i get my king over
to b8 or a7 okay and then i start
hinting at some rook h8h1 threats
and
at some point if i'm very very lucky i
get to the trade queens of the board and
the moment the queens come off you you
definitely feel like it's a very very
obvious positive free roll for black
black premium which never loses those
but
sometimes maybe your your player on the
queen side and the center might be a bit
ahead the bishop on e2 is very
restricted like i will play g6 g5 the
knight on d1 like you play knight e3
right yeah and then you want like you
ask yourself okay where is it going from
here
c4 c4 is a decent square but i will play
i will play g65 as early as possible
just to kind of further restrict the
light pieces
and i just don't see how white does
anything uh but
obviously that doesn't mean that black
is objectively much better i just like
in terms of stylistic preference i
probably prefer the black side yeah just
remember that rocket shade is a threat
rookie chain is right right so you can't
play 93. no of course yeah i was just
making a general point about
restricting squares currently yeah you
can't allow rook chain yeah it's like if
i'm in white's shoes i'd like my queen
for argument's sake on b4 so let's see
so we can give a couple of checks
actually i think if we want to equalize
yeah either this or you can go h7 c2 as
well i quite like h7 c2 because i think
that but potentially just makes a draw
on the spot h7 like if we don't believe
we're better here with white yeah i
think we can go queen h7 king c6 looks
normal i don't like right yeah and just
play queen c2 here
and just force me to step back yeah i
mean you can play queen c5 but then
queen e4 check and once again like i
should have a repetition there yeah at
least so it looks like this just more or
less makes you draw more or less makes
it drawn
on the spot
yeah if you want to play queen g5 here
and play for even that way i will you
know deal with my disappointment
harshly so yeah it feels like linear is
currently kind of considering if he
believes he is better
he will choose something else he will he
will find a way not to blunder okay i'm
sure and then he will continue well that
was my real question is if you
if you're linear and you're you're
thinking you're better
aren't you trying
really to play f4 and bring your bishop
to f3 and i'm sorry to interrupt you
guys but favi did go for this rook takes
g7 that you guys were mentioning so we
expect a handshake pretty soon yeah
they'll find a way to trade the rook for
the oh yeah
very nice yeah very nicely done guys
yeah and uh
no piece oh whoa that's uh that's a
slightly kind of a
no it's not because the game already
ended what i mean is you can't like on
g7 it's not a move
ah okay
people still do no
they don't but they're wrong
okay fair enough
knowing knowing laws of chess is
useful but not something i can boast any
you know
particular and very nicely done by hans
there by the way because i was i was
trying to calculate this uh because
unveiled got this absolutely gorgeous
position by 251 where he he avoided
losing any pawns on the third round this
is his max yeah and you can play rugby
1v5 check here and make a very
comfortable draw there but hans just
goes king g8 says king of six rook f1 i
will not even be a pawn down because f4
is a check and after that we take either
on e4 or on g4 exactly
yeah you can you can take on g4 yeah you
can even throw in
okay king h7 and even in that position
white has absolutely nothing there yeah
like yeah
you know one check
of one check but even after the check
with the f7 pawn hanging it is still
just an immediate draw okay two rook f4
exactly
k7 rook takes e4 check and then rook
takes g4 like i collect everything
it's uh
it's a harvest yes so the move king g8
and rook a check on the board
oops
and i assume king g7 and i think the
players are actually looking at each
other and
repeating the position three times
so
three draws and that does leave us with
and uh yeah linear has played q7 check
so we could actually have everything
disappear of the boards at exactly the
same time and then a bit of a q here
right
to you know storm our studios
i remember this this is a classic
i really didn't like playing in these
tournament these round robin tournaments
in europe but i didn't really have a lot
of choice so what happened is we would
always have the starting rounds at one
o'clock in the afternoon except
for the very last round
the very last round the organizers in
order to save
money on their hotel
would
have the last round play it nine o'clock
in the morning completely throwing all
the players
off their usual schedule so that they
could have the closing ceremony in the
evening
olympiad
and it was a hastings tournament and
the players had kind of assembled at 10
o'clock in the morning you know people
drifting in having a coffee
looked it looks looks like they were
hungover
and
novelastimal horde
20 minutes into the round no
blastomalhorn 40 minutes in the round no
valastro horn then at 50 minutes
boom
the door swing open and a very angry
blastomall heart comes in you know it is
terrible
no wake up call and i must run like
rabbits
it was this run like rabbit and
everybody ended their games i think
nobody could take it anymore draw draw
draw
run like rabbit to tournament hall
um
run like rabbit to tournament hall
run like rabbit to alejandro
as
as uh we're getting people uh set up
uh to talk to
alejandra alejandro thank you yasser
here we have a very theoretical draw
between lebanon with black and fabiano
carnotellas how deep did you know all of
this
yeah
i've lost one time like this against
fabiano in a rapid game and
20 to yeah
and then i kind of said okay i have to
study this line as well
and well it's a it's a very funny line
actually you know uh
i mean there is this i i'm i will show
some cheapo for yes sir you know if you
go back
instead of
king to
c2
yeah king b2 is the move and then there
is rook fd8
so rook hd1
i think it's e4
and uh let's say white goes ruth has d8
rook takes d8
rook takes d8
bishop d8 and let's say c4
i'm i mean it's probably with king b3
first but anyway black has this idea f5
and king b3
there is this nice move bishop h4
wow g3 of 4 yeah yes
this is for you my dear yes sir
that's gorgeous
and so bishop c1 e3 and black is fine
and it's just fine
maybe even better even better right
probably better yeah yeah
but wow what a line
yeah you have this subtleties i mean you
have to know them and king c2 of course
is the most principled move
and it forces black to you know pay
attention
but
i knew that it's a bit passive but you
know i have my play we are yannie
ponichi on the show since they finished
so early mentioned that this move a5 he
also knew that he was also important uh
when did you discover this move a5
when i pressed the spacebar
love it a correct answer
he played this move after rook v8 check
it seemed that rook did somehow rattled
him
i think king d3 is not the move i think
a5 is the most a5 right away yeah and
black has to you know pay a little bit
attention i think first you need to play
f6 king f7
then uh it's a draw i mean uh black has
enough counter play white is not in time
to push but after king d3 i started
getting some hopes because i thought
well my rook gets active you never know
because
yeah i
well he has to probably play king c2
were you surprised
we thought king kingifart here in the
studio but what after rookie eight you
go back
but rookie six is you know you
you get nervous about this type of thing
i think at this point he was already
nervous after king d3 yeah yeah because
you know you don't know i mean if you
take and c5 probably there is enough
activity for white but
it's a pawn after all it is so in the
game he went back and you didn't repeat
you thought maybe i can start pressing
yeah i knew that there is
nothing for black but i just thought you
know
just to keep some pressure in the game
you know it's a chance and after h4 well
the only thing i calculated i mean after
this rook d4 stuff that
uh somehow um
a5 h4 king b3
i'm faster than him rook d3 king a4 g3
takes
and rook g2 rook a8
king h7 a6 and bishop g1
and somehow i'm faster because
c5 i have
uh
a2
uh uh
sorry maybe h through or rook a2 or k2
yeah and then king b3 h3 yeah h3 and you
are promoting your pawn yes
yeah you're promoting your phone maybe
it's our h3 first
somehow it was all working for me yeah
h3 and remedial and then rocket too yeah
wow a lot to consider um yeah because
rook h8 is impossible i take a7 and then
i take on a3 it's like checkers and i
collect all the pawns show me again like
this one goes through
yeah
it's like checkers yeah ah yes
i see it regressive a3 covering the a
file takes takes but bishop takes c5 and
you collect everything yeah very nice so
it did seem like it got a little
dangerous for him but always yeah but
the rook a6 was a good move
and uh
what i realized is that if i take well i
have to take on c4 because now rook g4
um
um there is i mean he's faster i think
now he doesn't need to
well he doesn't need to put the king in
awkward position right oh no we're
trying to calculate this we couldn't
figure it out yeah so how does this go
i thought he would give a check
uh king a7 and a6
takes and takes king b3 bishop g1 bishop
g1
um
with eight seventeen yeah a7 he can do
yeah
you have to take it right i don't think
rook g3 helps you
i don't think here it does
and then well
he is in time with bishop d6
right
h3 bishop d6 even just not playing c5 at
all you remember k1 maybe you know
yeah also yeah
this can get tricky it's gonna get
tricky because he still has a pawn yeah
and then after taking b3 that the issue
is i cannot go rook c8
because uh he has bishop e1
ah that's annoying and this bonus and if
i commit with g5 then you know
after bishop c3 or bishop d2 i mean the
pawns just get too loose
and the rook is too active and if i go
rook g4 instead of rook c1
i think the issue here is rook c6
and after i i take
he can go a6 bishop g1 bishop c5
and i think it's a draw it's a draw
button you're not pushing for a win on
this one no no
all right so you went for rook c1 and he
played bishop c3 and it said it seemed
that king h7 rook 87 was finally yeah
yeah now now it seems he gets enough
counter play because my rook is cut
right
well fascinating theoretical duo uh for
you it seemed like you were just a one
move better prepared than favi is that
your feeling
no i think he knew that the position is
drawn i think his king d3 was just
a bit careless and then he had to
you know pay attention
not to get in trouble well but he paid
just about enough attention and i draw a
logical result seems like that's going
to be the
name of the game today for very logical
but good draws
yeah yeah i mean it's an extremely
exciting day
[Laughter]
we have some more decisive than others
well thank you levon for joining us here
in the studio two more games to go
thank you lavon thank you for the cheapo
that was very good that was a very very
beautiful cheaper
bishop h4 f4 in the e3 made my day and
then f takes e3 e3 f3 right actually
queen's on the f file not not the more
exciting than that um did we have by the
way a a repetition and a drop not yet no
uh alert is consistent
trying to figure out if he wants to play
queen c5 and play and play on because
we've had a couple of uh only ones
already a couple okay sorry i missed i
missed the second repetition right so
yeah he he i mean king seven will be a
claim right but quincy five is still i
mean the game continues i really don't
believe black is better off the queen c5
but alireza in general he you know likes
playing chess and uh right well we'll
will continue if he feels like it we'll
get more interviews yeah let's jump back
to alejandro who is this time with fabi
bobby it seemed like a very heavy
theoretical game did you ever feel that
you suddenly got in the back foot
i don't know i think it was always a
draw i mean
after king d3
yeah i guess i can play c5 or something
i mean there's i think pretty much every
move is objectively drawn here
uh and king d3 should be one of them but
then he made it interesting he played
this rook d4
did you know that this move rook did had
to be met with king c2 or did you just
start thinking during the game no i i
didn't know um i mean i was thinking for
quite a while at probably like at least
20 minutes i'm not sure exactly and yeah
king e4 rookie and i just couldn't
figure out if this bishop ending is a
draw uh let me go one second king four
rookie eight uh this one that you were
mentioning king d3 rookie sex right yeah
i wasn't sure if this is a draw i had a
feeling it probably is but i thought
here it it will be rather difficult to
foresee everything and king c2
um wrote d4 i
i thought i should have more than one
way to draw more than one way to draw
after this it felt to me like this is a
very george position
uh yeah a5 h4 um like in this position i
just thought there should be more
multiple moves that that would make a
draw here but rook a6 is the most
straightforward one
yes okay six and uh levon showed us
quite a few
lines in this position yeah rook g4 is
is probably dubious for the
i see the variation
that he gave on the screen yeah um it
might also be a drop after a6 at least
he has to prove the draw right uh and
and so what he did is normal i mean
after king b3 again he has many moves
which should be a draw like i feel like
rook g4 rook c6 is a draw yes correct on
that one rook g2 a6 and like rook g3 or
i mean i think maybe bishop g1 bishop c5
gets dangerous maybe yes maybe that's
bad but i thought rook g3 would be a
draw at some moment he wrote two three
immediately at some some moment he
throws his check in and and we probably
go back and forth like i have let's say
king b2 here
for example um
yeah he he can go back or because if
bishop won bishop c5 then he doesn't
have access to the a-file that's why i
keep my key on the b file right uh
anyway some lines like this felt very
drush and
uh rook c1 bishop c3 khm i started to
feel like maybe there's some like tiny
tribe but i couldn't see it at all like
first of all rooks e6 bishop e5 it rook
c6 here bishop b5 is important
uh and i guess it's also a draw but then
i felt like i have to prove it because
of king b2 he has this tricky move
rookie one
and oh
and
we get some rook ending where i think
that i'm the one who has to prove a draw
right even if you get the rook somehow
at the end there's a lot of puns coming
yeah it'll take me a long time to get
the rook so
um rook a7 was just like um
just a way to clean up the game because
i have like rook b6 i have rook a8 but
rook 8 i thought was a try and then i
saw this f6 move and again he kind of
trades
trades the bishops and i thought
why go through this suddenly he's the
one who has a bishop you mean yeah a6
bishop b5
um
take take i mean again should be a draw
but why but but yeah but why why would i
do this when rook a7
is a completely clinical force draw
you've debated this particular
line quite often do you feel like it's
running out of steam or do you feel
there's still stuff to look at here
i think it might be running out of steam
i mean i played this against levon in
2018 twice exactly this long castle
thing well we the first time i um
i think i'm we both messed something up
in the opening and we got something else
entirely but this specific end game
after a long castle i played a rapid
um
tie break against him which was very
important we were playing a match and
and based on that game i won the match
and i think like i once played a match
against grishouk where i must have
played this exact line like five times
and uh so yeah what are the showdowns
here in saint louis yeah in 2017.
so
i think i'm probably the player who's
played this c3d5 ed5 the most like i i
have
easily a dozen games in this position
after 85 queen e5 bishops before queen
d6 so
uh
i might have to look for different
directions
you've played levon over 150 times
considering rapid blitz and classical
and that's just over the board do you
feel it ever gets difficult to prepare
against such a player
um
not so much but i did realize that some
of the
openings that he plays we have discussed
and so i had to think about that before
the game
uh like
he he at some point had a phase where he
was playing the b5 bishop c5 spanish
archangel very frequently and we started
checking it so i had to think about what
i would play that we hadn't specifically
looked at
and
okay this line we've never really
checked because it's such a deadline
there's no point checking it i was
hoping that he because it's kind of
forgotten by now it's like this was
resolved years ago that i i i was hoping
he had maybe forgotten some details
about this line and then it's very
tricky but he remembered it extremely
extremely well yeah certainly hasn't far
out forgotten any of these details
perhaps that loss really
uh put him in his memory well thank you
for joining us here i think we'll have a
couple more interviews let me just
update really quickly what's going on
between dominguez and alireza no draw it
seems like uh louis is the one declining
a draw with the move queen c5 so we'll
still explain for a win here uh well
that would how do you play for one after
queen like it well because you didn't
play king d7 on claim a draw because it
would be a three-pole repetition like
queen c5 queen e4 between d5 queen c2
king is this really his attempt yeah d7
queen 7 king d8 that's
yeah i guess i mean if you're
and off we go if you're
19 and super ambitious then
then this is what you do
we remember those days don't we no
all right fabi thank you for joining us
here in the studio
thank you uh youth is uh wasted on the
young um
take a look once again about at this
queen c5 uh what's your take here after
this queen e4 check us yeah i'm i'm
surprised by it because
really it doesn't look very attractive
you will have to play yeah exactly
that's why we said like you you're king
actively actively aiming at this
position and
the pieces are really not where you
would assume they need to be but making
a good move in this position like you
can play knight c3 even like which is a
kind of a cute little trick but it
doesn't really do very much because roxy
three queen h8 of course will not get
blundered right the queen goes to some
kind of a normal square e5 or perhaps i
don't know maybe g5
and the latin c3 is like i would like to
play
yeah i would like to play 94 but i'm
worried i will blunder into something
like rook c1 connected also even the 6d5
and this position drives it away very
comfortably for
uh for black yeah i will end up going to
a lesser square won't i yeah
so i mean it looks really weird but if
you go back to that position yeah like
kinking g8
giving more checks drives the king to b8
where it wants to be right that's black
yeah black wants to play rook c1 next
move
as well as maybe maybe
no queens
yeah but look at rooksy one yeah roxy
one is the idea here exactly uh and
you're you're looking for a good move
with white and i've kind of struggled
like you can you can obviously go knight
e3 right i'm guessing the reply is we
give a check we give a check from g5
okay i've got a block in this yeah you
have to play knight g4 and then we we
look for a good move perhaps queen e7
and then king c7 or something i don't
know just i i want my king on b8
so you do this with black like if if the
rule gets attacked like you play queen
h6 here i play i suppose rook c5 just to
put it on a good defensive square
and then i want to play king xi7 when i
want to play it on king v8 and then we
just play great i don't think black is
running necessarily all that many risks
here
but
it also doesn't really look like a
particularly good winning attempt right
so it is it is very much exactly as as
uh
described yeah it's those
pieces
the minor pieces get themselves
coordinated don't they yeah and uh well
some some might be yeah it might happen
but i just i do see it as a three result
game uh yeah i'm kind of pleased though
to see ali
uh just keeping up the challenge just
saying
is time a factor by the way peter no
it's more 38 i mean
yeah like a linear is down to 20 minutes
against 33 but it's moved 30 no not 38
36 currently but right uh no they have
plenty of time for the first time
nobody will be in in the first time
trouble they might have a second a
second side note which which might get
exciting but the first one really is a
non-issue here
all right and let us uh take a pause
from our analysis and jump to alejandra
who's with hans
hans a draw here against nvla player
that you fought a lot in blitz how do
you feel going against them in classical
chats yeah we played this match in uh
paris
so
i'm quite acquainted and we've played
many blitz matches under casual
circumstances
and under
we've played blitz matches in many
different settings with let's say unique
heading
so
you know
it's safe to say that um
i am acquainted with uh
him personally and his chess definitely
much more than other players here he
surprises you a little bit doesn't use
his usual e4 which he tries to do as
most as possible in classical chess
instead we get this kind of grunfeld
dish position what were your thoughts
going into this variation yeah well
after the game i said you know what was
the last time playing out of three in
glasgow i said i couldn't remember so he
simply and and i think that is a sign
that
forgetting not to check knight f3
to be honest i only looked it looked at
e4 and uh
even i think we played
100 blitz games never once i see not
played of course it was a surprise but
so after knight of three even on the
first provide it makes such a big
decision right because there's so many
implications of moon knight f3 so first
i'm trying to understand okay
why not c4 um why not d4 y out of three
and usually when people start with
knight f3
uh it means that they want to go g3 um
sometimes it means that they want to go
c4 without allowing e5 so i was trying
to sort of understand where things were
going so i could
sort of
understand
where i could avoid being put in a
position where i'm going to be
forced to be precise right um and
obviously with a knight of three g3 it's
actually quite a dangerous system um
and uh so
there are a lot of ways that black can
actually go wrong and run into deep prep
so i went for the one thing i
knew think you didn't expect let's just
start after knight takes d5 because this
is the first moment i want to talk about
okay um so i actually going for this
line i i've never
checked this too deeply however there's
a game uh
do you i think it was jokopian against
theodorum
pretty sure uh theodore was black around
the corner was white and it was in the
summer chess classic and uh they made a
quick draw knight b5 bishop e6 95
bishops eight so i remembered following
this quick draw and i've seen i think
this quick draw twice
so my conclusion was that it's probably
not that bad
and
my play seems pretty simple here i i
recalled something after knight c3
take take
after knight c6 these positions that are
that are symmetrical sort of just lead
to a lot of
just liquidation so i wasn't too worried
here and he definitely
wasn't going to be able to fully punish
me because he had no idea how can he
expect this
or you know because when you play that
through g3 you're doing a lot of work
before the game
and i don't even think he didn't have a
rest that he played the game yesterday
so yeah
regardless um this first critical moment
knight b3 was obviously an interesting
surprise um
and knight before i thought it was the
most logical
um
he plays knight c3 knight c6 yeah
anticipate all of this bishop d2 was a
nice idea you know you want to
play a3 so bishop five rick c1
um
rick c8
a3 knight a6 now i was slightly worried
about the position but what i played is
an extremely concrete solution um i was
the 996 is a bit awkward
but
the standard b3 is also a bit awkward so
we've got this weird sort of uh tension
between these two knights otherwise i
thought that my bish105 was slightly
better than the bishop one d2
i guess they're opposite colors but
they're sort of the
corresponding bishops in this
very symmetrical structure
so when you play bishop b3
um i thought bishop 6 was the only move
because i wanted to be extremely
concrete take advantage of this week 9th
and
he played queen c2 bishop
uh bishop b4 queen d7 and honestly if
you look at my time i like literally was
playing so quickly right i spent much
time in the opening so
with i just after yesterday i just
decided okay i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna just gonna follow my
intuition just gonna play quickly and if
it goes wrong it goes wrong so uh this
this queen e6 like this
it's actually really interesting this
motif for the queen e6
and this specific pressure i haven't
seen before but
it's uh there's actually um
it's not a weird i've seen there's
in this vessel this is an idea and it's
completely different structure but i
thought that it was a really great
square because it's simultaneously okay
i guess the main problem okay if you
sort of look at compare the pieces right
you've got the the main issue in these
positions a lot of pieces is the queen
placement so the queen on c2 was a bit
off
like um
for example let's say instead of queen
g7 i played bishop takes e4 okay
um
this position but before right yeah yeah
so let's say once the queen takes on e4
then everything is ready to then do you
want is coming and my queen is very
misplaced yeah so the main sort of
dynamic and an issue was sort of uh
solving the the queen placement and if
the queen placement is solved with the
landscape bishops being traded uh the
pressure from my g7 bishop especially
with the weakness on b2 combined with a3
being already included
i felt that
obviously the not on a6 isn't ideal and
could be dominated i didn't feel like uh
he could he had to be very direct at
least he was gonna do anything and okay
with the game this gf5 idea is obviously
quite weird but
my bishop g7 is protecting very well the
bishop e3 is terrible and as we saw in
the game he had to play knight d4 where
you're not worried about anything else
in this position 95 crossed my mind and
we discussed this after the game so
there were just so many even i was just
struggling to make sense of this um
like i considered 94 but i was just
waiting maybe i was like wait that's not
there's so many moves i was like even
just looking at this bishop made my head
hurt and uh i i was just like okay it
was 94 94 then i'll think i don't know
if i'd land before maybe but i was just
even struggling to just on like i'm
sorry but i i cannot
like
you know
before
you know to play chess you need to be in
such a serene state you know you need to
sleep well
you need to not be on social media five
hours a day you need to like go to the
game with a clear mind and you need to
be like calm you have to pull a yasser
you have to you can't be like you know
have a million different things entering
your head at once and and uh even you
know before this wesley game i was told
actually just to force a draw because
playing chess on these conditions is
simply no one can can can do this
and i didn't do that and i pay the price
but you know
anyways i think
it happened but
after 95 i was this rick g8 we discussed
rook z8 and out of four queen e4 yeah
and there was also queen e5 as well but
queen e4 take take maybe you can arg uh
queen takes e4 fa4 uh let's say rook
takes d8 uh rook takes d8 let's say rook
c2 maybe you can argue some slight pull
but i just think this bishop one g7 is
so strong and
there isn't really a direct
plan maybe f5 is a bit weak but i
thought oh no sorry there's rook d1 rook
b1 here maybe yeah i just thought this
was actually fine for you perhaps they
were a little bit more worried about
this cool move rook d3 but it's of
course difficult to find rig d3 well
yeah
yeah i didn't consider rook t3 but uh
yeah rick date would probably be the
most natural continuation uh perhaps had
some hope for knight d4 but i don't
think it was working no i definitely
didn't yeah i definitely wasn't yeah i i
think that's i think at least i knew
that i was not capable of calculating at
all this game
you got to this position and you seemed
like you were forced to calculate i
guess some of them well the race is so
simple like come on it's just so it's
just easy right what do you mean
calculate like like if you go back all
my all-news are basically forced like if
you can suggest another canon move no no
after rook at five what what were your
thought processes maybe rook desyncs
yeah
i thought
the nice let's say this rook d5 well
there's check right let's check it's
like king f6 i didn't see
i don't i wasn't sure
where the queen was was going
maybe
oh you can take
oh maybe am i getting mated wow that's
no you're not no you're not
wait but brooke on d1 is hanging you
know with check yes
and then i can i'm sorry
is this like a joke
like a prank like could i take the rook
like i'm sorry
it's just a draw it's just a draw
yeah okay
you're spending some time with too much
time with the computers
i'm i'm sorry like
i don't
i think this variation speaks for
the itself but of course i saw um that
rookie six but i usually assume like if
frequencies is happening and i'm taking
a rook
and the kid rick and chef is hey i can't
imagine a situation where i'm losing so
i think that that wasn't i think that
was a logical way for me i don't know if
it was necessary to calculate this far
no and then you made a very comfortable
draw after the move queen before did you
feel it would i say yeah the rooks are
traded it's
just
maybe i'm
white is to be preferred but yeah tell
us a little bit about your loss
yesterday uh they say that you learn a
lot from losses why would they say
this is true
they are they thou correct
um uh
i do learn a lot from my losses and
there was actually a period
where
i would never have like
non i would never draw like there was a
period i think when i was around 2500
that i went to a tournament it was seven
wins two losses next tournament was like
nine games one draw it was like five i
won four games in a row then i lost five
games in a row and the next tournament
so so uh
my style has become a bit more solid
but i've always i think losses are of
course a lot to learn from and there's
so much to learn from this game first of
all um
the pet trough was uh a unique uh
surprise of course i was still ready and
i played normally but i think that the
the thing that really should be learned
especially when you're playing guys
against wesley that
risk aversion is i think a really really
important skill in chess and um
i think that if you look at someone like
wesley he's
he never i don't know if he
not he doesn't really blow people off
the board but he is just so so precise
so accurate and he simply never will
make a blunder or a mistake extremely
very rarely so
i think this is a conscious thing and at
many points early on in this opening i
could have made decisions that would
maybe never lose the game right right
and
that is obviously a lesson to be learned
but considering the circumstances
like uh i don't think i need to even
verbalize the
the mental pressure and everything
that's going on like
maybe only i can understand this or
people who have been through similar
things but
i assure you playing chess
doing something sitting there for five
hours trying to keep a clear head trying
to compete even i'm completely this is
my first super tournament of my life
so this is extremely it's extremely
difficult
but you know i love chess and i'm just
enjoying playing
but i wouldn't be lying if i'm just
really hoping for this
i really just i i
i can't play chess anymore this is this
is uh to play some of these conditions
is absolutely ridiculous gotta say it's
not bad to not be able to play chess and
still make a draw against mvl with the
black pieces yeah but
of course uh mbl was also um having a
difficult tournament so maybe he wasn't
as
like i think mvl having a good
tournament would have played e4 and
things would have been much more
combative
but in this case uh based on the opening
and based on
the tournament situation i think that uh
it's fine result and i think i played
pretty well i don't think i made
significant mistakes and i didn't get
into time pressure for no reason like i
have
in every and every game
hans we have a question from the
audience at least that's what our
producers have been telling us let's see
they're on the screen for hans given the
last couple of years of travel isolation
and now this drama do you have a support
network to lean on
from what do you what do you mean by a
support network
i didn't write this question
i would i would i think that the wording
is just
maybe a group of people that would be
supporting well
you know people that you can go to well
i live a pretty isolated life um
to be honest i i
i
and that's by choice
so
i will say that i have received
an insane amount of messages
i think every single person that i've
ever met or even played in chess has
sent me a message
and honestly all positive maybe one out
of 100 are negative
so
um at the early moments uh
when things were so when people were
saying he's planning messages after my
first interview this was obviously
really it was nice to see
and some articles written and obviously
that was supportive but in terms of
speaking to people
that's just my personal life so i don't
really care to to elaborate on that but
uh
i have a very small
um
i just
it's
i like to play chess and i like to do
all things chess and uh
i have people that i i
there's certainly people that i trust
that's true and people that i've talked
to but
yeah you can you could say yes i
wouldn't say a
group or network but i would say a group
of people but
you know this situation has certainly
showed the true colors of many people
well hans thank you for joining us i
know that you have two more games that
you want to finish your first super
tournament on a high note so we'll let
you rest thank you yeah two two quick
questions for your hands first of all
how did you do in those blitz matches
that you mentioned with mvl when you
guys were yeah so combating yeah so i i
am so initially i was actually i'll give
context first i was going from armenia
to germany for the bundesliga and i got
a few days to burn so i was like why not
go to paris
and um
they arranged the match and there was a
two-set match um we played i believe
three plus one
two
to six i believe
and then we played
three three plus zero to six as well he
absolutely dominated me in the first
portion i think it was something it was
a huge stormy six one but the second
portion i won
then we played a four game tiebreaker
match that went 2-2
and then in the armageddon uh he beat me
but he was dead lost and even he will
admit that but it was it was a casual
match it was actually a lot of it was at
this chess bar and there's huge crowds
as well after every game they were
clapping so it was quite a unique format
but uh
i definitely think if you ask mvl and
there's a video of this there's a full
video of this me playing blitz against
the world the world blitz champion and
almost beating him in a long match so
if you guys want to see my blitzkills
i'm sure you can find that video against
the as i repeat the world blitz champion
uh yes you had a second question yeah do
you have a coach do you have a somebody
you work with
do you have a coach
i don't
yes but i would not like to reveal the
that's good enough for us that's good
enough yeah
is it good i have coach advisor the term
mentor you know it's
nice i have people
uh helping me uh i i decided after
yeah we're not really after maybe i
should get one
but actually you know uh yeah i would
actually like to first of all uh
pay tribute to to one of my first
coaches yasser you might know him john
grief yes and uh i was actually uh loved
in light of this entire situation i
would actually like to to to
actually speak about something because
now there's all the attention i'd like
to highlight someone very important um
when i was uh nine years old
i went to the uh
there was a coffee shop the i think it
was the blue danube and my dad would
take me there and these guys were like
average agent be 60 and i was nine years
old and i'd go there and i'd play blitz
against them um
just
every sunday and then it became multiple
times a week and i just played so much
blitz against these guys and one of the
people that i knew john grief who wanted
to get me a coach and
my family couldn't afford working with
him so this guy sponsored
the lessons and i was actually the last
person to work with him before he passed
away and he had no family and i was one
of the only people to see him
before he passed away and you know
a lot of my inspiration and my chess
passion came from him he was the us
champion
i think in 1971
he's played some beautiful games he beat
miguel night or if he's he he uh but it
was a really sad story because uh he
uh he never had any money he couldn't
make a career from chess and as the
astroplayer knows back then becoming a
professional chess was very difficult so
i just like to to to shine some light on
on his amazing impact on my career and
uh and his legacy because i don't want
that to be forgotten and i hope that
people remember him to be a great chess
player and he was a chess purist
absolutely you know he had health
problems and i'd go over for lessons and
he could barely walk but he was picking
me up a chocolate chip cookies and
lemonade and
and he really loved chess and uh i just
like to honor him because
and all of this uh uh just on all this
drama everything i just
if everyone's gonna listen to me then
i'm gonna at least talk about something
that's important to me
so that's beautiful thank you so much
for that uh
cons because indeed uh i knew uh john
grief very well as you said a
former u.s champion and i remember we
drove down from edmonton to seattle and
we did it in one go we had one album
sergeant pepper's lonely hearts club
we had this tape deck and we played it
over and over and over and over again
for seven and a half hours hums good
luck in the remaining games thank you so
much for your comments thank you thank
you
absolutely yeah john green that was
really really really nice to
to to get a shout out yeah he was he's
good people too uh we have
what oh i'm on the wrong i i i went to
the wrong
uh game um
we have one game remaining yeah
absolutely and uh
very interestingly uh
uh yeah
after queen c5 we haven't seen
that took some time though that
definitely took some time and it's
interesting decision because we kind of
assumed uh of course forcing the king to
uh to g8 by giving a check from e4 and
and then giving
uh
back the check from situ and so on would
be it would be quite useful but
instead yeah a year after some thought
goes quimby to here
stopping okay shade more than anything
else i feel is is the reasoning here
because rook h8h1 is maybe
the one actual the one actual idea black
black has in these uh in these positions
at least so far
uh still an unusual decision i would
have i would have expected you you still
play queenie focusing two queen h7 and
then you think
uh but yeah linear has gone in a
different direction here but something i
really like about the little queen b2 is
if it is a prelude to f4 and bishop f3
in some kind of ideal scenarios yes you
very much you very much like to do that
especially then i could go like 93 and
f5 i feel like i could get something uh
some action going on for the white uh
side here
uh going on what did you think of the
interview very nice one yeah i thought i
thought uh you know the the feeling of
gratitude to your to your coaches is
something that is extremely familiar to
me i was i was very lucky with uh with
coaches in my life my childhood coach
she sort of introduced me to i mean my
parents introduced me to the game but
i probably didn't need too much
encouragement to sort of fall in love
with chess i was absolutely obsessed
with chess from the moment that was
shown to me but i think you're very
early coaches
the most important thing they can do is
not to uh you know let you get
disillusioned with the game not make it
into some kind of a drill not not
make you lose your your fascination for
the game as the game right and of
judging by what we've heard uh this is
what also happened with hans and it's
it's always very nice i think to to see
people pay pay tribute to their early
influences and uh yeah i thought that
was a very nice experience i i think
this idea is is very much the case that
we have this passion
and that these coaches uh don't destroy
the
passion by going no no no
but rather they go oh
good idea good idea
it's not that important yeah it's not
that important which opening repertoire
you end up one you know at the age of 12
and uh
this this all can be repaired but if if
somebody manages to kill off your love
for the game by the time by the time
you're you're a teenager something has
gone badly wrong and it's true uh yeah
it's always it's always good to see when
it doesn't happen
i remember one coach of mine i i i i
showed him a game i was very very proud
of jeffrey parsons he's like a 1900
player
and he applaud very very very very good
and it was only about three years later
that i realized well i have this very
very basic tactic of bishop e2 to b5
pinning the queen on c6 to the king and
he never pointed it out to me because
that kind of would have ruined
what came afterwards but it it was very
nice
an interesting non-teachable moment an
unteachable moment um alejandro we have
one game in progress and we've just kind
of been musing
over this move queen b2 i
kind of like it that's a decent move
everything is zero zero because what's
going to happen in the game
black's trying to trade queens
white's trying not to trade queens and
the war game is so wide open that you're
never going to really force me to trade
queens here with the white pieces and if
you ever go something like king c7 and i
start getting my pieces out there's no
real safety for the king like if you
could put it on a7 easily i think that
perhaps you can start thinking of
something but we can blinking b8 here
right because bishop sixpence c1
ah i missed that
dope
yeah but apparently i have queen f6 yeah
it's not so easy because you have a lot
of pawns hanging you never want to push
this pawn
because then once i get my bishop to e4
you are actually getting tied down on
the light squares you actually always
want to play the move d5 but as long as
i have a target on e6 i don't think that
white's really going to be worse queen
b2 on the board 9 minutes for linear 21
for alireza
i think draw is just still a huge
favorite here guys
it is yeah but it's interesting to see
uh and we've been talking about this
already that uh i think
uh it's hard for me to imagine that
ereza actually believes that he is you
know significantly better right uh and
the temptation to just go king d7 back
on move 36
and you know sky sign the scoresheets
yeah he kind of survived a somewhat
difficult examination in a line where i
think his opponent was at least slightly
better prepared uh
everything you know is
generally making a draw with the black
pieces against a strong player his
tournament situation is not really you
know banning stations he as we discussed
at the very very early
point in the show if everything like if
if every single game in this tournament
ends in the draw from here on out right
he ends up in in second place in the gt
standings right uh he does not actually
catch up to to wesley so him he probably
wants to win a game at some point like
obviously he wants to win a game at some
point but he probably needs to win a
game at some point right uh to to
overtake wesley in the gt standings but
black against lanier you know in a line
where lanier starts thinking and move 27
is maybe it's maybe not the most obvious
point where you you you feel like you
know this is my chance to win a game
yeah this is the one i target you know
maybe not so much
but alireza just like this is i don't
think this very much factors into his
thinking process right it's a position
which we haven't played out to to its
conclusion yet so we will play it out
now why not and it's very admirable to
see yeah and not something i you know
recognize very easily but
but something that i very much enjoy now
that i don't have to be you know doing
it myself nothing like the courage and
pushing and the envelope we're going to
take a short break and we're going to be
back with the conclusion of this very
exciting remaining game in round seven
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
[Music]
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility
a journalist's work revolves around the
truth
finding it
verifying it
and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories
offering facts that may have been
omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to st louis public radio
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
round seven of the sinful cup with only
one game remaining but it's it's
actually warming up quite nicely uh it
is with the way with the way it's going
and uh
the more they continue the more i uh
start to
very much be in favor of the decision by
the resident to not repeat because i
think it will be a very intricate uh
kind of a uh
end game with queens on yeah the
kind of a really strange material
balance here d5 played and uh linear
here making a move which i think was
very heavily indicated by the move
bishop e2 g3 on the previous move i
think bishop d3 was very much an
indication that uh he wants to prepare
the square the e2 square for the for the
king so that you no longer really have
to even worry about rook h8h1 which is
currently impossible
it's also a clever move specifically
because we were discussing how after
knight e3 if you play 93 instead of
bishop d3 uh just one move back yeah
black can play king b8 here because if
we take on a6 queen c1 check
forces the queen off the board and then
the bishop on e6
dies a horrible death exactly which is
not the case after bishop d3 because
after bishop d3 king b8 yeah we can take
on a6 and quincy one is not the check
because we've left
we've left our knight on d1 purposefully
still there in place and that causes
like a hugely important pawn on h6 this
is on exactly which is why there's a
play d65 instead
but after g65 i think maybe kingitsu
it's an understandable move it's a move
that linear was always intending to play
but he had the option of playing maybe
f3f4 and trying to actually undouble the
pawns break break the
the center for black with this idea of a
four or five which you keep on
mentioning like
it was something that was something
yeah and i think it's a good idea here
but when you chooses to choose again
king e2 not bad though
and
after the move queen d6 which by the way
is on the board and obviously like you
say you're you're you're prepping
i think alejandro was mentioning if you
can hide your king on a7 maybe you get
excited about uh your set of
circumstances but
i don't know it feels to me like white
is the one who's improving his pieces i
like the king on e2
i think the knight is coming to e3
although i don't think that's the
destination square probably g4 e5 now
exactly yes now now with the way pieces
are after enough 93 king v8 you have to
look at 9g 495 ideas exactly i'm still
not sure what it does on e5 there's
really no targets for there it's
blockading it's yes it's it's it's
centralized it's it's all of those
things all of those things are very very
nice but
okay but now that you've raised the
issue of
you know good looking night versus an
effective knight where would the knight
be that it's most effective d4 with the
pawn on f4
what would be it's unclear yeah
this is i think maybe the biggest issue
white has in this position is that
arguably the best square for that knight
is on e3
just because but that's a passive square
that's a square where you're very much
as long as it's on e3 your king only two
will be entirely safe it's a very very
good square
yeah in terms of like controlling the
squares around your king making sure
that your centralized king is going to
be
left uh untouched by whatever trouble
black can try to concoct but
in terms of placing it somewhere where
it can create any pressure against the
black setup i struggle to name a square
that's ask alejandro
i'm sure alejandra the computer says
it's about even but
what does it recommend as an ideal
construction setup for linear no it
actually likes bringing the knight to e5
guys and it's saying still about even
but starting to turn better for white
after the knight e3 you guys are
recommending king b8 which is absolutely
fine but all right i put my knight on g4
you gotta assume king a7 right knight e5
if i continue tickling here i don't know
where you put this queen gotta do
something b6 c6 i'll of course never
trade queens just never trade queens and
it's still fine for black but also meant
by night i'll go f4 what i achieve i'm
not so clear but on a humongously good
day
it is i play f4 f5
i trade off these pawns and then i can
start thinking about trading the queens
because that's a completely different
end game right yeah that's an endgame in
which i have a past pawn and i can
target d5 and remember now my knight's
not only one it's on e5 it must be doing
something
is it close to equal probably very close
to equal even in this position because
even in later cases black won't be
forced to trade the queens themselves
i'm just saying that in this particular
position it's still advantageous for
black but once f45 starts looming you
can start thinking that both sides are
interested in the queen trade and now
after 93 it's all arrested to play the
engine's thinking why is this midge
better 0.2 it's not very much but
they're starting to think that well the
two pieces are two pieces right
and is time a factor at all no it's
still move 40 so
we just reached move forward yeah gosh
it feels like after interviewing all of
these people like we're late in the day
of play but no uh it was a day it's a
fantastic preparation yeah it's either
it's quite remarkable because yeah they
they blitzed out so much in this game
like it felt like they reached move 26
like five hours ago right but
it's not like that and it only only just
reached uh originally
uh as as we watch
uh so there's going to be a
in the beginning a somewhat leisurely
second time control where you know they
reached 40 without any you know
particular alarms
position remains reasonably finely
balanced
and the other question then becomes uh
i think potentially a very important
question here in terms of how this game
transpires from here is
which side will find it easier to play
this position
in particular if it is for some reason
easier to play with black
uh linear could start burning time in
the second time control and that could
lead into trouble because if you like if
uh if alireza succeeds in making linear
interested enough right so that you know
he he starts feeling okay maybe i have a
bite here you know maybe maybe there is
something here that you know could could
on a good day give me give me winning
chances right
and then in the search of those winning
chances he leaves himself i don't know
five minutes for the rest of the game
again somebody as practically strong as
as ali reza is and ereza is a very very
strong practical player
we've seen it time and time again and
he'll try to take advantage of that uh
yeah that could be a differential that
could be a very interesting uh second
time trouble whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa okay i'm not i'm not we're not no
i'm not expecting
that move e6
e5 that
that is a very kind of an unusual
decision i guess his point is
currently we can only attack the pawn on
d5 additionally with the queen
at the time being we can play queen b3
right so which i'm pretty sure he's
intending to play rook g8 because
something like i mean this would be a
dream come true for white i mean
you know if we could get
knight c4 and ambush before oh or
mission before knights before first
sorry i did it the wrong way yeah yeah
so five yeah but this is an extremely
extremely committal move which i did not
expect at all and
now the question becomes
does white ever somehow have time to
play i don't know bishop c2 b3 but we're
we're also taking away the bishop away
from the e4 square i know we just we're
so
desperately interested in getting the
pawn to d4
uh
we don't like this movie
uh
alejandro i it does it have an immediate
refutation or is it
uh we we we're doubtful about this move
raises our heckles nothing immediate as
far as losing or losing advantage but if
you see the engine it already says plus
point eight no longer though zero zero
two that it was considering with the
knight blockading here the problem is as
you guys have mentioned that if i block
the light squares oh this bishop's gonna
become a monster so we start thinking
about how to do it and there's a couple
of ways to try to coax black into
pushing his pawns a little bit further
right especially this move d5 d4 i
actually want you to play it right uh
the first one is to first attack the
rook here on
uh c8 yep ask it where it's gonna go if
you go to f8 or something like this then
i start attacking the d5 pawn either
with queen b3 or queen d2 and again you
don't have you don't want to play d4 if
you put the rook on d8 first maybe i can
start playing the move knight g4 and
again you don't have d4 you have to
start defending things with the rook now
you have this cool move queen d2 and
sometimes you're gonna be hinting at
bishop e4 like for example if you're
king b8 you can start hinting that
bishop before just to remove the rook
from the defense rook date and then go
back to c2 and now i have enough time to
put my bishop on b3 and start harassing
this pawn now what is black's point
because e4 never works is never
desirable you've kind of given yourself
a free weakness it looks very appealing
visually to put both pawns on the fourth
round control a lot of squares but the
more you analyze it the more you realize
these pawns don't want to move you don't
want to play forever right it's not easy
to prepare this at all and even if you
did the knight on e3 is perfectly uh
placed after a trade of pawns d4 is
never a move you want to play either so
just because this pawn on e5 has
advanced d5 is weaker e5 itself is a
target you would like at some point for
one to go in front of the other but i
just don't see how that's ever going to
happen so i don't like the i i don't
like e5 i think it's visually attractive
but that's it it's not a good
strategical move and if i go with
peter's suggestion of right away bishop
c2 to b3 not a bad move i was taking a
look at it you do kind of have to go
king b8 you have to liberate this at
some point and the only problem is that
after bishop b3 yeah now g4 g3 starts
coming in yeah that's exactly it's not
about d4
it's d4 with the problem that d3 is
coming very quickly and after this i i
think i can play d3 direct now d3
doesn't work directly because king d1
i'll ignore that but queen d5 with the
idea of e4 and d3 specifically in this
position also threatening rook takes c4
uh keeps the balance for
black queen b3 already on the board i
expect rook d8 to be blitzed out yeah
has to be blitz style has to be blitzed
down you can never play any other move
in that position right the engines
didn't like queen b3 as much as some of
the alternatives i was suggesting even
though they were perhaps not the most
natural moves queen b3 already puts the
pressure on the d5 pawn maybe slightly
better for white already maybe you can
even start with the move bishop c2 in
this position trying to get the queen
away somewhere i'm not sure where and
then b3 maybe maybe d3 right like for
example let's go i actually like that
queen d3 in this position
queen c5 yeah put the bishop and
something like this the engines don't
think it's absolutely horrible for black
but
i mean those light squares you know yeah
bishop on e4 one day i'll find a a
really good square for the night as well
yeah this is one of those positions
where the engine thinks it's equal
because it's strong enough to prevent
you from getting that bishop to e4 right
but you also feel that if black slips
slightly right and you are able to
coordinate this with white properly then
the position is strategically hopeless
interesting and
i just wanted to say that we have a
special we've wrapped this special
anastasia has been
doing her best at uh rounding up the
players and having interviews and
keeping the social media but she caught
up with a local international master
eric rosen and had a nice interview for
your pleasure
[Music]
here we are with eric rosen in saint
louis chess club eric i know that you
live very near to this place like how
happened that you're in saint louis and
lives so not so far away
yeah i just live a few blocks uh away um
i've been living here since uh 2019 i
actually shared an apartment with eric
hansen
uh 2019 through uh basically 2021 and
then eventually moved out and uh got my
own place and it's been nice and having
gatherings and playing some ping pong
and um
it's super nice to be so close to the
chess club yeah exactly because it's
like now saint louis is a capital of
american chess or maybe even world chess
i was wondering how many grand masters
visited your house these days oh i've
lost count uh i mean within the last
week it's probably been
between
five and ten um
definitely some some very strong players
and very strong uh bug house action so
it's been super fun to have so many
strong players in town
yeah exactly and you were the one who
had this big like to play against the
world champion magnus carlson before the
tournament has started how was it to
play against the world champion even
though it was in simultaneous exhibition
yeah i was super grateful for it uh
because i was not expecting to get a
chance to play him and
now looking back on it i'm one of the
few people that got to play him this uh
this whole event so
uh yeah it was kind of surreal because i
played him online a few times before but
never like over the board so it's
different experience i felt a lot of
pressure but
i really tried to give him a hard fight
and
yeah it was a good game and i
filmed the whole thing i put on youtube
did some fun analysis so i hope people
uh can find that and watch and enjoy it
and learn a thing or two from it yeah
that's for sure and yes as you mentioned
you were one of the luckiest people that
you managed to play against him and uh
then what who what did you feel when you
learned the news that actually magnus
was drew from the tournament like what
was your first uh emotions
yeah it was very shocking like i didn't
know what to think but uh
yeah in times like this when there's a
lot of unknown information like you just
have to listen to everyone and see
what's going on and be patient for more
information to come out yeah exactly i
mean lots of information came out these
days but i don't think you have made any
stream on this topic and like
can you explain why
yeah well i was going the day magnus
withdrew i was going to post our game
analysis recap to youtube but then he
withdrew and i thought it was bad timing
so i did a very short like 90 second
video just to inform people i'm holding
off on posting the recap here's what
happened uh let's wait to hear more
information
um
but yeah it's uh it's one of these
things which is like we're continuing
continually learning
more things and i think it's it's
important to be pat
it's important to be patient
and also be kind of
compassionate and empathetic with
everyone involved
and uh important to listen and that's
kind of where we're at right now yeah
but many many streamers are making
really hundreds of new followers you
know using the the story the drama which
is happening right now like don't you
feel that maybe it's a good time you
know for to get more and more views and
more and more followers you know
yeah um
for me i've i try and keep my content
more chess focused and
of course it's it's interesting but i
still want to provide like the
more family-friendly educational content
so i've been doing some streams and some
youtube videos
um but i don't want to make any like
affirmative statements or anything
before
kind of we see the big picture so yeah
that's really nice of you and i i was
wondering i mean today you came here to
saint lucia's club and you took some
photos of the players i know that you
like photography but actually if you had
a choice like what is your the most
favorite thing to do like to be a
streamer to be a photographer a player
like what do you enjoy the most
i really like the balance i mean taking
photos it's certainly less stressful
than actually playing chess and to just
watch the intensity of an event like
this
the previous event i photographed the
was the world championship in dubai uh
which is also very very interesting um
just to capture
um but i i like the balance i like being
able to
to capture the moment but also do the
streams and provide educate educational
content
um but also compete from time to time
too so it's nice to wear multiple hats
yeah and okay now we are on the seventh
round of sinful hub like uh what do you
think about the event itself i mean now
that magnus is not playing like what do
you think about the games and uh
any any comments
yeah i think um i mean it's been a lot
of exciting chess of course there's been
some things distracting from the games
themselves but uh you know a lot of like
hard fought battles and um interesting
opening preparation from all players so
as a chess fan it's uh
the chess is certainly not disappointing
yeah exactly thank you so much eric for
your time and all the best in all your
activities thanks so much
[Music]
and we're back eric is always one of the
more sort of positive people around the
chess you know it was always very very
nice to talk to him and
does a lot of good things for uh for our
game and including the birthday party i
think his house was absolutely wall to
wall grand masters playing ping pong and
bug house i got in some bug house action
i was i was throwing some patties but
failing to jump on the bandwagon how
dare he i mean
he's been quiet
he's certainly a
very respected
local eric thank you so very much going
to this position and the more i'm
looking at it you know i'm
feeling like i'd rather have linear
absolutely in linear shoes i really like
this move bishop it's very logical this
is what we need three there should be
three it's uh
easy
and this is just this is the strategic
lemon this is where it all goes wrong
when you suddenly get your bishop on uh
the
perfect i think he's already played king
b8 and has he
i think something just got played very
recently or maybe i'm mistaken i thought
i saw something on the screen but my
point is once you go with 65 your entire
game now as you can see like black no
longer really has any proactive ideas at
all because your entire game is tied to
the protection of the pawn on g5 and the
pawns are really stuck you you you don't
want to be forced to play d4
and probably
you're not really going to have the
timing or it's extremely unlikely
yeah so
conversely
from white's point of view well he's got
a very clear point he wants to attack it
with everything and once again we're
watching an endgame where basically
three pieces play against two right it
seems very simplistic but when you're
attacking a weakness
it actually counts because you either
will have to give it up or push it
forward right and if we are provoking
successfully provoking g5d4 here once
again the mobility for black is gone
entirely like right this structure is
sort of the final structure they will
have in this game right and then the
question very much becomes exactly as
you were describing does white have
enough time to somehow reorient
ourselves get the bishop to e4 not the
knight before right right 34 is
extremely solid but with the knight on
e4 if you could like we continue here
for three moves right on queen c592 okay
king a7
knight e4 queen wherever i don't know c7
before it doesn't matter okay
the point about this is that the 94 is
extremely solid but it's sort of
wrongly placed in terms of putting any
pressure on the e5 precisely pretty is a
picture
in a way it's in it's in the way
actually of our pressure against the e5
pawn conversely yeah
uh here on c4 uh we start thinking about
ideas of uh
actually
like if i can play here queen let's say
and the other way around let's say queen
b3 yes can be three king a7 yes which
before rook g7
yes
knight b2 rookie 793 yes thank you so
much yeah this is
this is the dream yeah this is where
they should be this is ideal really this
is where they should be and this
position probably collapses i don't
really imagine this holds no uh so this
is the strategic loss that alejandro was
talking about yes
uh it can happen very quickly this is
why i was so shocked by 65 because if we
go back to that move 40. and we once
again discuss the position let's say uh
yeah king b8 knight g4 i don't know king
a8 maybe so that on a7 it doesn't come
into into checks okay 95 and then some
some move i don't know queen c5 whatever
okay
yeah
yeah i've learned in 97
sorry sorry i'm sorry queen c7 most of
my larger point is i really don't quite
understand how white is to make uh any
progress if you push a four it's it's
going to become a bit of a target maybe
not much of a target but a bit of a
target
your bishop on d3 is still entirely
restricted by by the pawns on d5 and e6
which work as a very very uh you know
useful kind of a wave breaker which you
know denies pretty much every single
square that bishop on d3
i am yeah i
he might still eventually be okay in
this game but i think
i would be extremely hard-pressed to
convince myself to play 65 in this
progression because it just goes against
my general feeling of not wanting to
give white a clear-cut plan not wanting
to give the bishop on d3 any targets and
again we're looking at these positions
after bishop c2
with an intensity suddenly on white's
side
is if we can coax the d-pawn
to go to the d i don't think it's even a
question i think yeah it's gonna happen
yeah quincy three should be three is
going to happen i don't think there's
any particularly useful way of stopping
it uh the question is whether this
actually is enough after you know
something like something like this and
then we put pieces on the c file like d4
knight c4 queen c5
and uh
you know we claim that
it will be difficult to you know
reorient these pieces the way we would
like it
9294 is obviously available on tap but i
don't think it's best
i i would very much like to have the
bishop there but i can't really for the
for the life of me currently figure out
how to get there well nightbeat i like
this just very slow yeah i need to exist
but it's just very very slow
um alejandro jump right in uh where
where
we've warmed up to the task we think
that uh lanier is for choice but at the
same time
it's there's a lot of work ahead of him
accurate as always it's not easy king b8
i think still is the best move in this
position we're trying this move queen d3
among others yep queen e3 in this
position you have queen c5
and now you want to play bishop b3 yep
and problem in this in this position is
that you go d4 and knight c4 we went all
the way here we got to king a7 and now
the question is how do you get how do
you improve right knight b2 or try
knight b2 but thanks for letting my
queen in
and now the position doesn't really
collapse in the end game i was looking
at this yeah and i think that if i at
this point i have my bishop on e4 my
dyno d3 already
then it would be fine but
uh it it actually coaxes the bishop all
the way to e4 the engine does and it
says b5 and you'll get enough counter
play like this
knight d3 rookie 8 and it looks
dangerous but at the end of the day i do
have a clear plan king b6 a5 and
continue to push the pawns so it's still
far from easy i mean if you put this
into two engines i still think that the
draw is the most likely result um it's
just that it's becoming unpleasant for
black to make moves uh for example if
you don't play them with king b8 in this
position then maybe you
maybe you don't have that many good
ideas
yes it's just it's become very very hard
to uh to to nominate anything proactive
i think we're for now alireza at least
for the next foreseeable future eliza
will be playing kind of a waiting game
just burying the immediate threats
and you know hoping hoping not to miss
anything hoping not to
not to have to make too many concessions
the the material is limited enough and
the black king on a7 i think by this
point is safe enough that you still
assume that there should be enough
counterplay and black isn't really doing
that poorly but
yeah i'm pretty sure you you you always
be quiet here exactly
exactly so and by the way i want to say
to our audience thank you so much for
uh tuning in and uh joining us for our
broadcast certainly we do this for you
and if you have any questions absolutely
for our collective selves you know how
you either drill
right
at stl chess club on twitter or any any
of the live chats are always we we
always welcome
uh
feedback constructive and otherwise
maybe less constructive even more
enjoyable
yeah i was gonna say what did you think
about this move knight b2 queen c1 this
very very specific ending
i'd be worried with black i mean i would
be too but again that was kind of funny
it is so easy to imagine how this goes
badly wrong uh i did right with b5 might
be five no nine ninety three or eight
eight and you you imagine white somehow
managing to play a four trading e5 for
the f1 and then exactly and then
starting to push the second one right i
mean it looks borderline lost but
obviously it's not that easy to organize
because if f4 currently effort the
bishop will hang and if we start with
let's say bishop c6 uh instead of f4
right
after
let's say b6 or k7
you at least have to consider that f4
might run into e4 even though i'm not
sure how good that is because f4 will
work for life yeah yeah that's the
question maybe we've lost actually so
yeah and uh there's now doesn't even
play king b8 he finally produces a move
he goes queen c5 queens it should be
very similar anyway i don't think he
changes uh the the character of the
position in great deal we're playing it
on the other move order right queen king
ba queen d3 about queen c5 was the
movement yeah it's great
it should pretty much be the same
perhaps he is like
quincy five here in the doesn't it
really indicate much but
preserves some options for black but i
really don't think the king stays in the
center right like you can like if you
want to like
make a parody of this the entire thing
after queen g3 you can play i don't know
king c6 and claim i am playing three
against three
in the protection of my g5 pawn i do
have another an additional piece i can i
can use it
nobody ever does this like it's just
even if it doesn't lose immediately i
think your entire being will be
you know protesting yeah exactly against
this treatment
um it was funny i mean this is this is a
done deal and all that good stuff uh
bishop c2 uh
a different thought had crossed my mind
and that was the idea of a2a4 so the
idea what i have is i'm i want to stop
you from playing b5
in those positions where i want to
encourage before i know and i was
thinking that uh i could play that for
for
leaving the queen on b3 in order uh
to tell me you don't actually think that
yes
no a4 exactly was actually a very no
very serious effort i really really
dislike this sorry because i think you
you want to encourage b5 first of all
and secondly importantly i think yes i
very much like the idea that my bishop
has an
anchor square on v3 ah that i want my
bishop 1b3 to be on the back that's a
good point i
i like protected pieces as well and the
whole point what
peter is saying is that on the b3 square
it's anchored firmly and protected
firmly by the a2 currently i don't know
why i need this but it just makes it
makes playing this position just so much
more comfortable when you know that you
know the the likelihood of any tactical
resources available to your opponent due
to you know loose pieces dropping off
right as dr nunwood
would say like it just it's severely
diminished by the fact that everything
in my position is protected
and it's it's just such a natural
instinct for me to always sort of
gravitate to setups where
everything is decayed
you can't blunder yeah it's just
uh bishop on b3 anchor knight on e3
nicely protected as well
uh queen c5 uh 23 23 already played yeah
look uh
any
different uh it
would appear that it's going to be
transpositional unless as you said king
sees no
it's not happening
i can i can imagine uh
sort of
taking the bull by the horns here and
just pushing before i'm provoked but i
think it's a mist i think you want to
wait for bishop b3 i think you want the
bishop as far away from the e4 square as
possible so you want to wait until
you're forced to play d5d4 and you only
you only play g5 before then it does
occur
that uh
when you do it
now you're not actually yeah no threats
but like how do we use it
yeah
yeah i don't i don't think we can i i
think we were probably back to
somebody's long maneuver by the way
it's these positions where i in
particular thought that anatoly karpov
was without peer
he had this ability
to
reorganize and he would do it over a
lengthy kind of period maneuvering he
would know that his bishop belongs on e4
his knight belongs on d3 just as you had
made the setup and it was sort of like
he'd find it
inevitably his pieces would find those
those squares and he had this
extraordinarily
gifted style
a highly technical style of getting his
pieces to the ideal squares they're not
ideal yet but he would not know
yeah
and jump in alejandro uh
if you if you were to call this you
still think it's a draw
i think so yeah yeah i think it's
favorite
but
it's just more difficult to play for
black
like objectively i do think it's a draw
i think that from a practical point of
view you lose it once in a while yeah
absolutely you can you can imagine this
going uh going astray for black because
yeah
and on the other hand it's very very
difficult to imagine like a sequence of
events which leads for this to become
dangerous for white again right like you
would need to blunder some very very
kind of non-obvious tactics like
i don't know
some kind of a scenario would be like i
go rook h8 here and white just ignores
it and goes
d4 and c4 here for instance like rook h8
and we go for some reason knight g2
right and black goes quincy 194 rook h1
but white just basically needs to be
asleep white white needs to say yeah i'm
not going to pay attention to anything
that you're doing and i will only wake
up when it's like mate and three uh uh
why why would that even and even here
maybe should be one d1
might hold for two it is hold certainly
yeah like the position is so sturdy now
that
i really don't think i can imagine
you know anything that does not involve
a blunder of a piece in one move
that
uh you know destabilizes it enough for
black to have winning chances of course
it can happen over the like over the
course of a long game
and it probably will be a reasonably
long game from here but
yeah the the e5d4
uh set up by i'm surprised either as i
chose it
definitely also just uh suggest that
after you're yeah and you go back yeah
you're just going back yeah yeah and
then you lose it because f3f4 happens
afterwards exactly exactly as i said
like this is just completely ridiculous
this is how things really go wrong in in
a hurry
um
and again i'm i'm forcibly reminded of
the game
that ali reza won
against shakariar where he was just kind
of worse and then in the course of like
six move boom boom boom boom everybody
just went wrong for jack but it was a
very different situation because there
was
uh shahriar was clearly much better i
think
yeah he will be sort of ruining the day
where he just
did not i think he had plenty of time
and he decided that you know expediency
and uh time management concerns were
more important than perhaps thinking
through things cleanly
but
still it was a mess it was a position
with plenty of pieces on the board with
like active pieces for uh for ali reza
right and uh
and then yes you can uh suddenly blunder
into a very strong attack as well as as
indeed happened to to shock here
like you're you're not blundering into
anything here with white it's just so
solid
i don't think you you can
at least not the way it looks right now
well again just your chess culture
anchored squares put the bishop no
no double attacks no no
i want everything under control yeah
exactly uh feels very
very solid i i feel like i'm
particularly attracted to it right now
because for for whatever reason i'm
currently struggling to keep my eyes
open that i inside of the lights
specifically today or something but i
i do appear to like badly need to get my
eyes closed and with your eyes closed in
this position you much prefer that no
pieces are hanging
you know even even if you uh uh some
plunder something it's probably not
going to lead to you losing a full piece
in one move right uh so yeah i'm very
much in uh
periodically at penny of the dinner
conversations that i attend uh the
question of blindfold chess
comes up
especially here we have timor gardiev
who is
trying to break the blindfold records if
he hasn't already
what is
what's your your figure
easy for you to do four games blindfold
i tried uh it's an interesting topic
because
for a longest time i wanted to actually
try doing this live and i got it at some
point i got an offer from i think a club
in denmark if i remember correctly they
invited me to
uh to do a blindfold simul and then it
somehow fell through i think through
through a fault of mine not theirs i
think okay something did not quite work
in terms of my schedule and then i
started streaming
and uh
i figured that it's actually possible on
leeches
to stream
a blind blindfold blindfold simul yeah
obviously you know the stream needs to
trust you that you're not watching your
own stream on the other screen
uh but
you know my my my viewers were naive
enough to actually assume that yeah
and uh what did you manage um
i did
i think eight games
whoa and and then after i did two or
three of those online i was invited to
give a simul at a private function in
moscow i flew in and on the way in i
thought ha
maybe i should suggest it to those guys
that i can do it blindfold so i arrived
there and they were not actually
planning to do it as a blindfold simon
and i got there and i said if you're
interested we could try this
blindfolded and that was also i think
seven or eight boys i believe eight okay
and
live
it is just so much easier than online
because in real for for for a lifetime i
don't know how teamwork does it and for
for these really huge timers i'm
guessing it works slightly differently
maybe i don't know what the rules are in
terms of you breaking the record maybe
there are much stricter rules
but for a small company like this we
kept the normal rules of them making
moves one after the other okay and then
keeping eight boards in uh in your mind
when you know when you know that the
order stays the same right really wasn't
that much of a problem at all right i
did blunder one piece but on that board
i was winning so much
that it didn't really impact anything
whatsoever uh but online where the moves
come randomly like whoever makes a move
appears
on your screen you have to do all kinds
of weird mnemonics
to kind of
you know combine the username with the
position in your mind yeah and there i
definitely blundered stuff just lost
positions all together and had to be
held by chat occasionally so it wasn't a
very pure experiment and i think i lost
every single one i played
but i mean they were strong players i i
never filter for for strength for those
things so whoever like gets gets first
to to to see if they sit and uh yeah i i
think like i wouldn't lose them you like
08 or anything but i think i lost
two out of three maybe three out of
three that i did right it's still very
interesting to try yeah because it's
something that you don't try very often
and uh
it was a new challenge i thought it
would be interesting but
yeah i don't know in a live setting
with with ordered moves coming in
i think i can do 10 without too much
trouble above 10 i would need to do some
training right and then i think i still
be okay up to a certain number i don't
know what the number is what about you
not even close i i
respect
alejandro as we prepare for break just
the question for you as a chess coach
how do you encourage or do you encourage
blindfold chess skills
i think that everything i've read is
that chess blindfold skills specifically
playing chess blindfolded against the
number of people is just an avenue to
going crazy
madness madness
that's no actual practical value
i don't know i haven't really thought
about it too much i don't think that it
adds too much i can do some blindfolds
simultaneous without any preparation i
haven't done one in so long that i don't
know if that's any longer true right but
i don't really encourage it i actually
have read a lot of articles to
discourage it
interesting i remember they called them
seances and paul morphy would have a
seance in paris and he was celebrated
because he could do
uh i guess ten maybe even sometimes more
extraordinary we're going to take a
quick break we have a fascinating
position in front of us uh
very important for our grand chester
standings as ali reza is taking some
risk absolutely
this game with lanier will be back at
the end of in a short while
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the saint
louis chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the team's inception slough
obtained second best university at the
pan-american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry hill so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active
communities it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to
the late night shift so
it's only 5 p.m i can't really i know
it's but it feels like a pretty nice
very heavy day right yeah
and the game is really heating up and uh
unfortunately for me once again i every
so often i will make a mistake of
glancing at alejandro's board
because i i am at least not switching
the engine on my own board today uh
which you've got a great idea yeah but
unfortunately yeah and and it still is
finely balanced but it does feel that
alireza has done a good job of making
this about as unbalanced as the position
allows definitely making it interesting
for linear but here we are in the round
seven and we do have three of the four
games already decided uh peter they
there we have it uh all three games so
far today have ended in draws the one at
the top there was really kind of a
non-game chakrier i think was very very
disappointed by his game yesterday chose
today to just make a brief memory check
shut it down and shut it down again
and then we had two very interesting
games well
i think the the the karana iranian game
there was the more exciting of the two
but there were definitely intricate
moments in the in the mvl game against
hans neiman but so far three draws and
and game four could also have ended in a
repetition before the first time control
through that but instead of that alireza
chose to continue playing chose to to
push the action
every time this happens you say he's
playing for a win but honestly
uh i don't feel like this is necessarily
playing for a win this is just playing
right by the way by the way as we were
on our break we were considering this
position and we were asking
king a7 played king a7 queen c4 was
played yeah this was the choice by wheat
we we definitely had to ask ourselves
the question peter
what would have happened if we played
queen e4 this is very challenging it is
it is a challenging idea and uh in my
current
somewhat adult adult state i don't
really trust my own answers very much
but my idea was if black plays d4g3
check here i wanted actually to provoke
black to even give a check from a5 by
playing king g2 okay and now after queen
a5 checking g1 the reason i'm doing this
is if you play g2 here
your queen currently is
unconnected to the c1 square meaning
that you are not creating a threat of
quincy one check which you would be if i
played king d1 first and then you play
g3 g2 i mean obviously i can parry the
threat of quincy one check but i would
much rather not have to think about it
all together exactly so you want to
induce the queen to misplace itself on
a5 so my idea was king d2 queen a5 is
the only legal check black can give king
g1 and now e5 is hanging g2 is i think
completely empty i can take on e5 with
the knight or the queen whichever way i
like i think absolutely uh probably
prefer than the knight maybe but it's
unclear uh and
and then it becomes unbelievably
concrete because if the e5 pawn falls
and black doesn't get anything for it of
course that's what will entirely
collapse exactly and uh
as we were very curious about this and
uh you know not really looking forward
to being explained by a hundred exactly
why we're idiots
right here chose queen c4 which is a
kind of a more
uh conservative
conservative play here but i think it
might be
somewhat similar somewhat successful in
perhaps forcing the queens off yeah
because now suddenly any queen trade in
our king makes a b line to the e4 square
but minus three uh
i think i think i even know why it's
minus three i think i figured it out ah
you have clear our cobwebs alejandro
queen c4 good move
it's okay
everything everything's zeros everything
in chess is zero so it's okay what
yeah the problem of queenie for i think
is what you were looking at right yep k7
queen e4 d3 checking here check yep
that's not a check i blended rook hey
didn't i yes
what i actually blundered was rook g8
after queen takes d3 okay cheetah had
seen but queen takes d3 and the row goes
back to this is this is i the moment i
saw the evaluation i instantly
recognized what i blundered as is often
the case yeah like the moment you know
that you have blundered the one piece
that wasn't defended peter i mean the
knight was defended the bishop was
defended you managed to find her a queen
uh but queen c4 there for alejandro
yeah and now queen i5 is the top engine
move you can also play d3 just don't
follow it up with queen a5 in this
position because queen c3 is pretty
painful now your e5 is actually hanging
and takes takes d2 you have knight e3 or
bishop d1 i think we should do one
second one's probably stronger and uh
you're gonna start shedding material at
some point negative 694 will collect the
spawn e5 is hanging immediately so queen
c4 can take i mean this is pretty clear
this end game is just busted king d3
king e4 bishop d3 is going to come very
quickly
uh i don't think you can play this
i don't think anybody plays that so
queen a5 is one way because it does run
in d3
i think queen e7 is not so bad either
but you start getting worried that
bishop c2 bishop b4 comes i think a
human solution is to first play d3 okay
force the king to d2 and then play queen
e7
at least you got your pawn to d3 the
bishop doesn't reroute so easily to the
e4 square
but it's still a game we still have a
lot of moves to consider here knight e3
is possible queen e4 is possible the
engine is thinking it's only 0.2
advantage nothing too serious just yet
but of course if you rather pick a side
like the
last hour
would you take white yeah the minor
pieces are beginning to flex
i would put it that way d3 check
yeah but that's such a committal choice
though
and then a quiet ish move queen e7
uh
yeah that just feels so wrong right this
is again i just feel like i'm getting my
pawns into trouble well i think the yeah
there's just going to be counter play
here connected with uh
yeah the queen gets into like the c3
square or well like rookie for qd5 queen
before or something like that and then i
will play
yeah
the queen before here
queen b4 yeah i want to play queen c3
and start giving checks positions like
this i think is what because the king on
a7 remains extremely safe so black has
some leeway okay yes the opponent e5
collapsed but suddenly the king on d1 is
not as safe as it used to be we
definitely have some card to play
against it so
um yeah it could still turn into a mess
and particularly if i reza chooses the
move d43 check because if you don't play
d43 check then white perhaps
reestablishes control plays bishop c2
the the option never comes again you
know right like if you want to do it you
probably want to do it now before before
something like this happens yeah they
put the bishop on yeah i will say though
that if we talk about this like no no
keep that position on the board okay uh
that's queen 27 yeah yeah in terms of
these types of positions where the
bishop gets to e4 we have somewhat
misplaced our knight right we would
really want oh d3 please uh yeah bring
it back like black black goes sounds
like rook d6 b6 and claims that i mean
i've blended q5 check but just as a kind
of a
as a kind of a setup right before would
be six and uh
yeah if the light is on a good square
here in particular if it's if it's a
good square d3 right it feels borderline
winning for white already but the light
is sort of very far away from from those
squares and black will develop some kind
of counter play there yeah it will be to
check or
uh or something like this perhaps we
could go like rook g7 c7 c5 put it on c5
and claim that now i've protected my
entire structure and your knight is just
so far away from ideal squares it will
take it maybe four moves to
yeah
to you know solve the the only reason
i'd ever want the knight on g4 is if my
king was in g2 and somehow i felt that
it was necessary to plug up at the g
file queen c4 on the board
alejandro now or never d4 d3 check
and the engine says
zero zero zero yeah queen a5 is also
zeros queen a5 yes i was mentioning i
wonder why queen a5 bishop c2 is not
great because we're not fine but you got
rick d5 oh rook d5 c5 so this actually
yeah this setup ah this is what you
wanted actually black c5 is a good
square for the rock in pretty much every
single situation you can definitely
relate to that i think
um
interestingly uh linear is back to being
sort of in control control on the clock
because alireza is down to nine minutes
well i think because of an eight-minute
thing right now by the president um
so it's it's nine versus nineteen and in
this very very complicated position and
yeah i wonder
and
maybe maybe he doesn't even wonder but
for me i would at this point if i had
this position with black right now and
nine against 19 on the clock
at least part of my cpu
it would be occupied by the question why
didn't i play uh king d7 after quincy
two check yeah uh and
i wonder if foley reza who is a a much
younger much more ambitious person than
right then
yeah he probably doesn't spend a single
moment the moment's thought on this but
for me i i would be somewhat questioning
my
uh
my
life decisions at this point yeah i
think that that's probably one of the
worst habits i have as a chess player is
i
definitely carry the baggage of an
earlier experience where it's like you
know i i'm winning out of the opening
and suddenly i've spoiled it now it's a
draw and i have to reconcile and be
objective
and yeah i will eventually get to that
moment where i am objective but only
after i pounded myself for being an
idiot for 10 minutes first
an unbelievably important skill sort of
playing playing what's in front of you
completely forgetting everything that
went on before as much as possible it's
completely forgetting it's just
difficult and this is also why this is
this is a very well known phenomenon
that
if you miss something incredibly
major like you you miss a win
it's extremely beneficial to not notice
exactly
it's unbelievable how important it is to
continue missing it until the game is
over exactly exactly
because it spoils your mood so much if
you realize that you you had a tactic
which would have decided the game on the
spoiler perhaps saved the game on the
spot and as we as we talked d43 is
actually on the board so we'll see this
is this is becoming sharp again with the
queen on c5 with the queen on c5 right
d3 check
this most natural i think with the king
on d2 yeah i think so
i think so even though after queen e7
both the g5 square and the b4 square are
checks now and wouldn't be checks on d1
so i don't know yeah there's some
argument for king d1 i think that once
upon a is on d3 i'm not really i don't
really care about the e5 pawn that much
right yeah we are trying to just solve
the immediate issues and then we solve
the immediate issues we round up the d3
point eventually and that's how we try
absolutely yeah so when you go d3 king
d2 i think i play knight e3 against most
anything no right
yeah i don't disagree i think it's very
logical i think it's very logical no but
this is becoming incredibly concrete now
but uh this variation where i i think we
got here in in the previous
iteration i think bishop do you want
bishop d1 makes sense but
this is bad isn't this just terror i
mean
is it isn't that losing
it could very well be yeah i mean you're
losing but i don't think you're going to
make any progress with the knight on e3
yeah i think i think bishop d1 is
stronger at least we're winning
funnily enough i was actually going to
play bishop to the next one and then you
know round up uh no with this guy but by
starting with bishop d1 we're also
forcing black to spend the tempo
different different
e5 that's a term
i think two actually because rook d5 is
the only way to keep two alive at the
time being and we go knight e3 now and
we've basically won two tempi exactly
and now we can play your knight of one
next movie just pick up on g2 no this is
horrible like you you occasionally will
somehow save this but obviously it's
like completely unplayable yeah you
never ever choose this
over anything else like as long as you
have any other choices you're you're
choosing anything else i agreed uh so
yeah finish seven and yeah you can play
93 as alejandro is indicating just
trying to solidify kind of make sure we
don't blunder anything put put things in
front of checks and then pick up the
pawn d3 or there is this move queen e4
which uh i'm guessing wins some material
straight away but allows counterplay and
this is the kind of position i was
referring to earlier but with an extra
temper for black rook g4 okay
uh queen e5 quick before check king d1
king queen c3
which i think queen takes e5 might even
be a mistake and i don't think white is
at all better anymore because queen a1
queen b2 suddenly becomes a very very
uh serious problem also due to quincy
one check will do
that there are issues aren't there
well i mean i i have a draw here right
ah you have quincy once sorry yeah i'm
absolutely blanking on easy as geometry
yeah i i just completely blanked on the
fact that you have quincy one here
yeah that's a very good point
okay
so it's not the end of the line oh i
mean a5 at the end is just zeros
what
what did you just say
five at the line at the end of the line
is just zeros yeah that's just zeros
all the way all the way to this moment
and you just go a5 yeah and the thread
is a4 and then if you take on a5 we'll
play queen a1 check and your quincy one
will lose the bishop on the e5 that is
true
and why just can't do anything yeah
amazing
27 played yeah he's played queen e7 so
far yeah he's down to seven minutes
against 17 and a half
um yeah this is becoming very very touch
and go
well i
i'm sorry uh gentlemen i'm still trying
to get the zen at the position a4
and there's a
uh
maybe in this case i shouldn't be going
after the e5 pawn or if i'm going to
take it take it with the knight yeah i
think i think queen e3 is what i i
briefly more
still zeros after queen e3
wow
okay just a second is my queen getting
off sides yeah let's look at e3 yes
let's look at what happens if we try to
do it kind of in a conceptual manner
like just keep everything under control
i think we don't have good squares right
this doesn't look very
i mean i'm still i i've got everything
no bishop c4 takes g3 is currently the
threat on bishop d5v4 but bishop support
the xd3 is sort of the fastest way to
the d3 square right let's do it yeah so
how do we as a black how do we queen h4
maybe is not finished for queen c5 check
but maybe it's still okay because i have
king a i don't think i'm worried too
much queen h4
check i go to a8 a8
because if i get to the f2 pawn i i
think my my life
you know acquires new meanings
um and what exactly would those uh two
meanings be
those types of things yeah anyway the
flow um
i don't know uh can i
possibly
czech i guess that's right d1 can be one
i'm really feeling like i'm
taking liberties but i don't see the
i mean i'm ready to i'm ready to
leave chomp
yeah
i'm kind of stuck right because you
currently maybe don't really have a
threat or maybe you do you should d5
maybe queen takes e5 is playable because
rook takes g4 will have a check from e8
exactly but mainly i'm just struggling
to make a move here with black i would
like to make a kind of a proactive move
between a forest production but it
allows knight takes e5 because you no
longer have to cover the g1 square i do
you know are you you're right peter you
seriously i i agree with you i just i'm
i'm finding myself attracted to this
also
very interesting um
the threats are beginning
to be serious i still don't understand
the triple zeros alejandro help us out
we so you want to start with the moon
knight e3 right yeah we want to we
wanted to try just to keep everything as
bunched up as possible right go from
there rook d4 is inaccurate according to
the engines uh
you were trying which move sorry quincy
three queen c3 memory queen see it a
little more active but okay queen c3
yeah you're gonna have to start fighting
moves like king a8 here just so that you
can play all these attacking ideas
without allowing a check right but after
93 perhaps the since
the knight is not attacking e5 the
engine kind of prefers to go queen f8
defend this guy this way and try to
force the queen to the king's side so
like if you have queen e4 yeah then you
have rook d4 and you're on the queen is
on this side yeah so i'm going to be
able to have queen before chuck yeah we
kind of intuited that somehow the queen
was off sides
on the king's side but after your queen
f8 we could just
can we play bishop to d1 and slowly
slowly play for the rounding up of the
of the d-pawn i don't think you get
there i mean the queen comes to a3 now
now that the bishop is not defending
this pawn
and again nobody's attacking e5 queen c5
is not a threat
dude yeah it's it's just that you know
machines defend these types of positions
so so precisely that we're we're
obviously kind of struggling to make
headway against
uh against the engine here but i don't
think it's easy for black i think
uh queen of fate already like queen of
eight bishop d1 queen a3 gets played but
queen f8 is not going to be the most
obvious move in the position i think
restricting yourself from playing rogue
d4 will be already a reasonably serious
challenge that this is based on white
now playing the move knight e3 and i can
very well understand that lanier may
find himself attracted to c3
yeah queen c3 or queen e4 i think we see
three to a later to a lesser degree
because i think provoking black to play
five e4 is maybe i mean
i mean it's a move dang
i mean
if i get to destroy the base for for
that knight on g4 some tactics might
become available which weren't available
earlier i don't know if it's a good move
but it's definitely a move that you can
consider because
fe4 queen e4 like suddenly your your
pieces no longer have as much of a
grip or grip on the position as they as
they used
no denture grip
you know
okay and is time two two most important
things in life as as we all know are
uh good dentistry and soft toilet paper
wow
very important uh time is a factor or
not uh 12 and against seven uh obviously
to the end there will not be any any
additional now they'll be playing on
their 30 seconds
but i mean the the short answer is yes
this is a complicated position there's
plenty to calculate and they are down to
i mean single single digits for alireza
and
uh we all know linear will finish this
game on increment yes unless it ends
like in the next three minutes we'll be
playing on increment at some point
exactly
i think there's no escaping that truth
well chime in i hear alejandro after
this move queen e7 uh how could lanier
put the most um
what's the most testing line
uh that the engine would like white to
play
yeah so you want to like come up with
moves out of thin air you guys already
analyzed everything e4 there's queen c3
that's it that's it that's it that's it
there's no more i mean 93 does look
like one of those moves that seems very
solid especially with knight d5 coming
in many positions the engines think that
after queen f8 maybe here
you can start try knight d5 immediately
and then you force black to calculate
whether this pawn is takeable or not 93
already by the way played and the answer
is yes you can take it queen c5 check
king a8 and it might be a little scary
when you see an ip6 check right and you
realize i would actually be a lot more
scared uh scared by knight seven knight
a6 to which you have to play i think or
you can take well the quiz on f3 so you
can just go no no but like there's rook
g7 and i'm not winning that position
yeah queen b6 queen b6 king c this
position yeah like i got 37 i thought i
was winning but i'm not yeah it's
amazing you're not on material right
because the queen is covering c6 yeah
this is what i thought was very
dangerous all right boom 93 rook d4 uh
was played queen effect was not uh we
saw queen c3 and we saw queen c8 right
yeah and still quincy it i think is the
better try just so that you put
immediate threats on the king in case
the queen leaves but quick c3 might
still be okay rook d4 is definitely the
second choice of the nj we thought queen
of fate was a different a difficult move
to find wow all right thank you for that
alejandro rook d4 i must say that's yeah
you just made this move automatically
yeah that this is why i was saying
natural this is why i was saying the
queen of fate is like unlikely honestly
unlikely to happen because your hand
just plays with your
hair doctor strange love and just he
just plays just plays with before now
that now this is the pro i mean as
desirable as this might appear allowing
me to have this check and queen c3 and
that's the counter play peter that
you've been uh this needs to be this
needs to be controlled which is why
either queen c3 or perhaps coinciate
with the idea of coming back to c3 if
queen before check happens because we've
arguably won a tempo not lost a tempo
right by offering the queen trade which
i think i don't think black can accept
not now this would have been definitely
winning a tempo queen fa-80 bishop d5 i
mean we've definitely achieved something
here
okay yeah so like we're we're actually
slowly slowly getting to exactly the
setup that might win us the game the
bishop coming to e4 and then we start
slowly picking these things apart
because we've probably by that point
liquidated most of the counter play okay
but i think we see it is a difficult
move i still feel that
you are naturally drawn to queen c3
because uh the ones stay close to the
king it's close to the king controlling
the dark squares you know quote unquote
controlling the dark squares i think it
seems more natural to play this way but
obviously engines
know best
rook d4 queen c3
and again uh
we're just
eyeballing just incremental improvements
but suddenly
they could be winning mm-hmm
yeah
there you go
on the board very very understandable
and now well you got to make uh you got
to make a move and this is the
difficulty of black's position exactly
and finding out something useful to do
can't trade the queens
can't allow too many hops to happen
and at some point it's it's not exactly
zugswang but it is
is this the position where you're
supposed to play king a yes b8 so the
engine i remember you were saying the
engine was playing king a8 is king b8 uh
much worse not much worse
but it allows a couple of ideas
including bishop d5 we should define
queen h4 i guess this is sort of the
point of the the previous play uh yeah
so you have to now control queen h4
somehow
or at least attempt to
or you can encourage it yeah
exactly yeah like i i i saw i saw there
that knight g5 is one of the top
candidates i guess with the
g5 check f4
and then we have queen c7 check coming
in so we are we have a kind of a self to
safety valve there of quincy seven
knight d5 queen g
and f4 if you play like if you play like
queen g1 here i
have a perpetual on tap and then i can
take a question about the purpose so we
go we go queen c7 i guess king a7 and
then we look for something that is
stronger than the perpetual i don't know
if it exists because queen takes f2 does
appear to be quite very quite a strong
threat but yeah
maybe we can we can actually kind of
know what i wanted to suggest loses
um
hang on queen b6
he's gone queen a5 which is a very
clever move yeah trying to control queen
h4 i think i think the weirdest part in
that position that you have right now on
the board is that after queen c5 check
and f6e yeah queen f2 is not that
exactly this is what i was going to
suggest queen c5 king beat fe and if you
take one of two i go king c3 and weirdly
there is no follow-up
kind of jaw opening uh
well the rook is hanging and the two is
i mean we control the g1 square yes
we're very happy to jump on d4 and say
thank you see a little nervousness and
maybe a rocking going on with ali
i should be nervous right we've said for
so long this is harder to play for black
every time that we analyze these
positions white can do whatever right
and it almost feels that
if it's not better it's at least okay
yeah but
so often with black you find
even this variation that you guys just
went through it just lost right right
like g5 just lost if i if we go back to
the position before queen a5 knight d5
queen g5 already loses even though it's
like
let's say a very natural looking yeah so
you're supposed to play to a kind of
some kind of a conservative square like
d6 so yeah exactly
after knight d5 just just not not g5
check at all just play windy six keep
things under
control you still have to calculate f4
even here right
yes even here you have to calculate f4
yeah like if three or four here is
playable because the pawn ending will be
very easily winning if you take on d5
because i have to intake c5 check
exactly and that just leads us with a
very very easily winning pawn ending but
rookie five of course is not forced i
don't know what is better but
i do know rook d5 is not forest queen a5
oh sorry uh oops sorry sorry sorry
rook d4
i'm gonna just refresh my board in a
moment
and
it can be fine king ba queen a5 on the
board
no it's tricky because like bishop d5 v4
is now very much uh
what we always wanted to do yeah we
the problem with bishop d5 is that for
that one small moment queen h4 becomes
available again because there's no
because e5 is not no longer hanging so i
don't know if bishop d5 is actually a
threat right this moment but
yeah bishop c4 63 definitely is yeah
looks very reasonable i'm warming up to
this move i like this move a lot it kind
of freezes
the queen
to the pawn on e5 and
okay i i've got a very
clear and compelling idea i want to take
the spot
yeah
i think what we need to do to take a
look is yeah what i i was about to ask
alejandra and then i saw alejandro
asking himself
[Laughter]
actually trying to force bishop d5 to
happen like if i play queen f6 here
queen f6 attacking the player i mean
we're not actually attacking my problem
with this move is that we're creating
zero threats right
perhaps c5 v4 in some positions but
that's maybe the best of it but if if
bishop d5 does come in okay this is the
position i want to
ask
put on the board and
discuss queen h4 here
queen h4 here yeah and uh like what is
this
f2 is hanging
91 doesn't look right kingie one
definitely doesn't look right
now white's already lost oh we've we've
actually lost this yeah yeah
how have we managed to lose this well i
mean f2 is unpredictable right so uh
yeah this is quite remarkable still
because like i don't okay i understand
now i think i was going to say i can
still play knight g4 and keep things
under wraps but after knight g4 in this
position i think queen g5 check in g1
probably wins or something
uh
so yeah it's it it remains a very very
complicated position but i think you
just don't play bishop d5 you you
realize that your opponent is trying to
pretty much kind of
cajole you
into playing bishop d5 there and you
think right how about no
about avoiding uh walking into the trap
yeah bishop c4 for instance yeah and i
guess black goes like i don't know king
a8 here to step out of the check
to be able to play bishop d3 queen takes
f3
and then the game continues ah but now
there is no
there's no escaping queen takes a6 queen
h4 check would be a
failure so
uh i've already blundered like 25 mates
in the past three minutes and i haven't
really been playing a a game today i've
we've had a reasonably relaxed round so
how difficult it must be for the players
we're watching is
hard to hard to overstate for sure
and speaking of that
in the interview with hans i think he
made a really really good point hard to
play chess
with this whole
hurricane surrounding him i mean
stay focused absolutely i mean it
applies to him more than anybody else
you could maybe even make an argument
that only really applies to him and
nobody else in this tournament everybody
else you know it obviously affects
everybody
but
not directly like
everybody else just
has to think about it every now and
again but for him it's uh it's a country
it's been his entire life for the last
three days or so exactly clearly not
much fun for him
queen f6 uh alejandro uh
how is our evaluation going here
point three for white point three only
with the best move and the best move
won't be played so we can start looking
at the second alternative okay yeah yeah
i don't like those arrows on your screen
yeah okay i mean a4 or a3 apparently
it's
like this a3 this seems to be suggesting
this is a position of mutual
like why
like how how can this be a position of
mutual tutoring okay i can't take on f3
because of the e5 pawn but the idea that
i can play the move a3 yeah just which
yeah it makes
no
no
just just know yeah just know
and yeah and then
the chess culture yeah
absolutely yeah doesn't really
understand basic concepts such as
such as all pieces must be protected at
all times because otherwise you will
blunder them in time trouble correct
doesn't really doesn't seem to grasp
those you know very very simple ideas
this is very intricate and absolutely no
surprise that no move has
been forthcoming just yet
and once again uh linear down to seven
and i mean six and a half i guess by
this point again
three and a half okay now this is
becoming very very exciting
this is definitely a round saver from
from our point of view because uh
interesting as those theoretical battles
were they kind of fizzled yeah they were
extraordinary
and this is a very very unusual position
it didn't surprise me by the way when
lavonne and fabi came in and discussed
their game and their preparation that
both were very familiar especially fabi
as he said he had this ending numerous
times but what for me was amazing was
nepo coming in and just having an
awareness of this game oh yes this is
the
you know the the the night g4 english
attack night or
and
and you know king c2 is a move but king
b2 is the theoretical moves that nepo
just
their knowledge i just
wow yeah these days uh the the absolute
top players have an absolute like
breadth of
of uh
very solid knowledge you know in a lot
of areas like
pretty much nobody at the very top is a
is like a single serve specialist right
pretty much everybody goes both e4 and
d4 uh
depending on mood and opponent and
you know the weather yeah
so yeah people people just know a a
great great deal about opening theory in
particular and
jan just casually knowing everything
about every single game in the round it
was not a shock
it's still very impressive to watch
people just kind of
stumble into the studio and just provide
lectures
on all three positions
uh remarkable uh at least i found every
morning
uh alejandro again you're you work with
the
saint louis university chess team
you've won
the uh pan pacific uh world championship
uh pan american uh
chip uh are you teaching your players
that they have to be ambidextrous know
how to play e4 d4 knight f3 uh
know everything
i had a student come as a freshman very
ambitious
and this person said oh i'm a d4 player
but i'm absolutely ready to start doing
e4 i want to like graduate college
knowing both and i was like
hold on
chill for a second yeah finals hit this
time yeah midterms here right you have
this extra curriculars how about we just
uh fix
one or your d4 for now
call it a day i mean it's hard to
maintain a dual opening repertoire uh
when you are doing something else in
your life right
it's not like these players that are
absolutely 100 focused on chess then
it's a different business right
even for fabby how does he maintain his
uh extraordinary awareness if you will
of
all of these uh developments that are
constantly occurring i mean because when
he sits down and watches a movie he's
still space barring
really
yeah
oh my
no but the
joking aside the work ethic of the
top top players of today is
really to be envied and
these guys are not slackers
no i mean again they do have the tools
the databases the engines that do
help them considerably i mean i would
have liked to have had
those types of tools when i was studying
but you know i mean we had encyclopedias
of change it was it was obviously it was
obviously very very different and also
you have to say on on that question that
uh
our viewers asked and we kind of relate
to hans the question of the support
network yeah it may have been phrased
slightly uh slightly awkwardly awkwardly
yeah and enhance uh
perhaps
did not answer it
as as naturally as it
um was intended yeah but that's exactly
what
for him
it's good that he has people to talk to
the people to trust but for the top
players i think pretty much every single
top player in the world right now has
a very well established group of people
who you know
will space bar when you're sleeping and
and just generally give you give you
good advice give you uh give you ideas
to play in games and
it is invaluable to to have that
that
uh system in place whoa 95 play and
that's a draw fragrance knight d5 yeah i
guess that's just a draw for right
because queen takes f3 we will have to
give this perpetual
threatens
yeah there's a little bit too many
threats to
ignore yeah yeah i don't think we can
ignore all of that so we go queen c7
king a7 and we give the open d80 and we
give you a perpetual i don't think there
is much else but it's obviously very
safe for white as well uh you were
mentioning some no that was with the
rook on d8 some knight c7 check and
knight takes a6 yeah it's always with
the rook on d8 yeah and also the king
has to start on a different square for
that because
the way the pieces are here you can't
really well no
no no no draw free justices
wow
wow very curious are you running any
risks playing like this no still no yeah
still no everything under control
wow yeah this young man is uh
not very interested in
ending games
when there is still a game to be played
this is the second time where i like
generally i don't think it looks like
black is better here
right so he is just saying
you know let's continue playing i feel
like you know if you continue playing
i'm the one with the edge
if it feels unrelated to the objective
right exactly exactly it feels to i mean
when i i think about players who were
always spoiling for and there we have 93
who were always spoiling for a fight
alexander morizevich is one of those
names that comes to mind of a person
who's always provoking and continuing
and forcing he
he seemed to me to be
quite the fighter absolutely yeah he um
you know i've had also sort of
non-eventful games against him i think
it very much depends on how he felt on
the day but
uh
when he was in uh in in fine fettle so
there were very very few people in world
chess when he was in his prime who were
as combative and as
uh his entire repertoire it's not just
his sort of general attitude but also
his entire repertoire was built
to get
a difficult complicated positions not
necessarily positions that you know
anybody with him would enjoy right uh
yeah but
with positions which would challenge his
opponent to find difficult decisions and
yeah i've i've had many many a battle
against against alexander and it was
kind of a really weirdly streaky affair
because like i would win
i think i started by losing a bunch and
then there was a period when i was
beating him in pretty much every single
game we were playing and then i think it
went back again and i started losing and
lost a number in a row and then our path
kind of diverged and we kind of stopped
playing very often
uh
but i think i ended up being in the
minus
maybe in a small minus but in the minus
uh in in classical i wonder if that's
true actually who
who do you have in mind alejandro as a
player that you found
to always be spoiling for a fight
didn't matter if he was better if he was
worse
didn't matter let's play yeah let's play
i remember he actually like
he was slightly worse against me one of
the us championships right and he kept
trying he kept trying
until at some point it did kind of start
becoming dangerous in the game and
they're gonna draw okay yeah i wasn't i
wasn't wrong yeah apparently it's uh and
i mean four four four four two players
who've been we've never really played in
junior events we started playing when we
were both
somewhat established as reasonably
strong grandmasters right uh classical
score that's 26 games
14 of them decisive eight to six in his
favor wow that's about 50
right that's about fifty percent
decisive so yeah and and you guys were
really clobbering one oh yeah yeah there
was uh yeah and there was a lot of
streakiness there right
it went
right it went very very strictly
uh we've been seeing uh a
a repetition of these last
i mean i can't imagine somebody thinking
two minutes in this position letting you
know
yeah one second and then playing
something else like if he doesn't go 95
here it it really is just stunning
yeah
a little bit faster here we go
as well knight to d5
yeah
and
does that i'm i'm just looking how many
times
could the move queen d6 claim peter or
no not yet no came from e7 right
aha came from e7
yeah two minutes followers against 49
seconds for
falling here as we see on our screen
here
have you ever done that deliberately
played really slowly and in order to
encourage your opponent to
continue the game
you're kind of hoping he's he's going to
make i think i've had it done against me
but i don't think i've ever done this
myself i used to be a huge uh like i had
a very very big
time management issue when i was a kid
like i was
in constant time troubles and then it
somehow resolved itself
sort of on its own i grew out of it well
done without ever really doing anything
conscious about it i just stopped having
horrible time troubles
and now i'm back to having some issues
with time management as as i grow older
uh
but no i i mean as a toxic it exists but
it always felt to me that it's much
likelier to
you know to be counterproductive
the thing people sometimes do like
specifically to play slower to encourage
somebody to play in an equal position is
i think something that is almost never
seen what people do occasionally try
is in a very very poor position to also
leave yourself like a minute because
it's unlikely to get worse right and it
might provoke your opponent to stop
thinking exactly and uh
this maybe i have tried once or twice in
my life but even those examples are i
don't immediately remember like specific
games
it's somewhat legitimate
because
you know if you can let's say you have
15 minutes in a very poor position you
spend i don't know 12 of them or 13 of
them right trying to figure out as
precisely as possible what will be the
follow-up from here
and then
you you have this very clear mental
image in your head uh as to
as to what you will be replying to the
most obvious tries and you also are sort
of you know leaving yourself open like
you're
you're removing the
the guard yeah yeah exactly you're
leaving the guard down and saying please
please go in for the kill and maybe
uh this provokes your opponent into into
mistakes okay 95 now definitely i was
about to say is it an idea definitively
uh it is i mean
already could have been a claim
so there
uh yes yes i see queen f6 queen f6 queen
f6 he didn't claim yeah he didn't claim
and uh i mean once again time to
actually kind of stop the clock
30 seconds
i think it is perhaps time to stop the
clock here on uh yeah
yeah and there it is yeah all right
that's a draw then again between linear
dominguez and alareza ferrugia all he
did is to stop the clock tell the
orbiter what he's going to play and that
is it
yeah what a very very interesting and i
think actually very well played game
there will they will have been
inaccuracies in it but i don't recall a
single
actually very poor decision
i i think actually uh or the the the
decision to play e5 was arguably maybe
double-edged i mean that that was
that was opening up a kind of a
pandora's box but then after that he
played very well i i really i really do
think that uh
in terms of like general quality this
was a very very uh well-played game
well played around honestly yeah
a lot of well precise games well well
played round but because the the
preparation was just so
unbelievable i mean crazy
uh good preparation yes
today was yeah that there was the one
sort of somewhat non-theoretical game
between mvl and hans in which mvl but
basically had an advantage for about one
ply right if he plays 95 against of 94
and specifically if he finds the idea of
rook g3 there that the engine shows and
they did not find in the post-mortem i
think uh told us that they discussed it
uh after the game and they did not spot
that rook d3 even existed which i think
is kind of natural actually it's not an
easy move to see from a distance
uh that one wasn't very heavily
theoretical but everything else today
was
uh was a fight between people who who
know their stuff really really well this
is the one moment i just have it on my
screen where you were expecting the move
knight defense i wasn't alejandro
explained it to me i really wasn't
i'm nice
maybe that was the moment where mvl
could
uh try to squeeze a smidge
um alejandro i think we're just not
going to take any interviews after this
game i think we're
going to close the broadcast and in so
doing
by all means
give us the closing thoughts of a very
eventful round seven i like theoretical
duels i don't like when we have this
many
in one round and we're left with one
interesting one i did like this game a
lot i thought there was a lot of content
i liked how already kept playing on and
kept playing on even though at some
position it might have made his
situation dangerous
but that's the spirit you want to see
from a 19 year old kid right it doesn't
matter what position it is and who he
has who he is facing he wants to win the
grand chess tour right and that means
scoring some important points exactly
but for closing remarks i'm going to go
with anastasia absolutely
how are you anastasia yeah here we are i
mean for closing remarks and um first of
all i wanted to show you the short video
which i just took with hans neiman
leaving the studio some some time ago
and so his fans met him next to the
chess club you know took some photos
with him and he was sharing some
thoughts uh telling them that people
start started to recognize him in saint
louis he became a star clearly here
and
also
i mean he was chatting with them he
signed some autographs as well
and after that i just wanted to draw
your attention that couple of hours ago
uh 13th world champion gary kasparov
published
other tweets
in his twitter account actually asking
for more clear statement from chescom
and also saying that
actually it's not good all this drama is
not good for sponsors even though it's
still good for media and for social
media actually
so um i hope we will see gary kasparov
very soon in st louis and he will give
his his other thoughts and i also wanted
to show you this tweet from chess by
numbers which shows
actually the rates of rating of
different chess players and uh for
example from you can see here the
numbers that uh anish giri made
something in 20 24 months i mean this
race in 24 months
so he is a leader of this
you know race and he was not i don't
know if he was happy about it
but
so you can understand that all the
statistics is not so important let's say
but you can still see it here that hans
did it in 42 months so he jumped from
let's say this rating 458 to
2616. and then okay one tweet from mr
doji who is following closely the whole
drama and
one of his
followers compared to cheating in a way
to
awaiting the green light and then nobody
was coming so decided to cross the road
you know so it was just a funny tweet
you know
especially for peter swiddler and the
the last one uh i wanted just to
show it to alejandro just to cheer him
up i mean the whole world is discussing
his great uh skills he's a great
interviewer and the commentator and uh i
think it's nice to see this tweet also
in in social media if you would like to
see more information of course you can
go to
st louis chess club and granchester uh
twitter and instagram accounts as well
as facebook and you can also find lots
of
materials and youtube channel and twitch
channels so please follow us and stay
informed stay connected back to you yeah
cool calm and clear and connected we
endorsed that
excellent tweet no no
oh wonderful uh i think we have our
standings after that oh we're going to
wait for the standings but uh we know
who's on first wesley so yeah what's the
continues
with four with four draws in this round
we can actually give the standings
exactly the standings are uh wesley is
on four and a half out of seven which is
plus two the only person on plus two uh
ali reza and yann nippon she continued
to be the only two people on plus one
and then the same four people which are
i believe uh lanier fabi uh hans and uh
uh
the bond levon yeah are on 50 and the
same two people are on minus two it's
just that everybody moved up half a
point apart from wesley
who was
getting a bye today
well done peter
yeah
i'm so glad i've got this man next to me
this is wonderful well thank you so very
much everyone for
joining us and sharing your day tell
everybody where you're hanging out join
our social media and we'll see you all
tomorrow for round eight only two rounds
to go everything is still very much up
in the air so yeah do
do join in
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited